cnn's ratings
are down
90
wow that's bad you know a lot of people
like to rag on cnn and msnbc saying look
how look look their ratings are going
down let's prove everyone hates them and
i often would say something like yeah
but let's be real like after an election
year everybody's ratings take a big drop
and um you know i'd like to point out
like even our views went down you know
during in 2020 it was crazy we had like
150 000 people watching on an episode
talking about politics
and uh
i try to make sure we're being you know
fair and reasonable when we mock
mainstream and corporate press but now i
think it's fair to actually point out
their ratings are abysmal they can't
they're cnn's getting like 73 000
viewers in the key demo prime time
we get half a million on on youtube and
we're just some like internet yokel's
complaining the cameras
hey that's fantastic cnn they're on the
way out the narrative is busted it's not
working anymore and we're gonna have a
really good time ragging on the press
we've also got a bunch of crazy news
apparently ronald mcdonald house is
kicking out kids because they're not
vaccinated we got this crazy report from
bloomberg
eu regulators saying that vaccines the
booster shots too many can actually
cause problems for the immune system
similar to what we saw from the new york
times so as always we say make sure you
talk to a medical professional don't
take anything we say his advice but
that's a crazy report to come from
bloomberg and then a similar report
comes from new york times so we're going
to talk all about this joining us today
is bhatia anger sargon no relation to
sargon of akkad that we know
that we know of yeah sure
do you want to introduce yourself sure
yes thank you so much for having me i'm
so thrilled to be here with all of you
guys i'm a big big fan of tim so i'm
really excited to be here my name is
bhatia anger sargon i'm the deputy
opinion editor of newsweek and the
author of a book called bad news how
woke media is undermining democracy that
i'm sure we're going to get into and
we're just thrilled to be here it's
perfect too because you know we get this
report on cnn collapsing and we have you
booked at the same time just very often
we get guests and just align with these
stories we got luke hanging out i say
it's ten percent too little i think we
need a hundred percent ratings to go
down at cnn but that's just my own
personal perspective and if you're
looking for a synopsis of what actually
happened during the last two years i i
do believe the shirt that i'm wearing uh
takes the cake for it as it says fauci
lied people died and if you want to
spread this wonderful message of truth
you can on the
bestpoliticalshirts.com and because you
do i'm here i'm excited for this
conversation it should be fun thanks for
coming well hello everyone ian crossland
here burning the midnight oil building
free software with an amazing team of
developers and i usually start my day
around seven and end it around 5 a.m
it's been really intense and i'm happy
to be here
we could see that yeah
thank you thank you thank you and i am
also here in the corner pushing buttons
i'm delighted to have this author she's
also a second child which i highly value
second children are underrated we're the
best in the world what can i say
i'm excited for tonight it'll be a great
conversation before we get started head
over to
eatrightandfeelwell.com to get
biotrust's keto elevate c8mct
oil powder man that's a mouthful but
this is my uh medium chain triglyceride
powder if you are interested in being
healthy and maybe even losing some
weight go to eat right and feel well dot
com this stuff's awesome i mix it in my
coffee and smoothies and other things
like that i haven't been doing too much
of smoothies as of lately because i've
been doing keto but i used to before
and over the past several months i've
cut out most of the sugars i've been
getting most of my calories from fat i
don't want to say i'm i'm literally
doing like hardcore keto but i've been
doing dramatically lower carb much much
higher fat so it's like me kind of i'm
just not very strict with it i lost a
lot of weight i think i lost like 15 to
20 pounds already that's just me and
it's a personal uh a choice if you want
to look into this again eat right and
feel well.com you can get 51 off of your
keto elevate from biotrust and you will
also get a 60-day money-back guarantee
it inc ketoelevate provides your body
with only c8 the most ketogenic mct that
means it provides support for energy
levels healthy appetite management
mental clarity and focus athletic
performance keto elevate personally my
favorite uh mct powder on the market and
as a sponsor of the show we're totally
grateful that they help us do the jobs
we do especially when it aligns with
what i personally do that's fantastic
you'll get free shipping on every order
for every order today biotrust donates a
nutritious meal to a hungry child in
your honor through their partnership
with no kid hungry.org to date biotrust
has provided over 5 million meals to
hungry kids please help them hit their
goal of 6 million meals this year
free vip live health and fitness
coaching from biotrust's team of expert
nutrition and health coaches for life
with every order that's the one i can
never believe because that right there
is just absolutely worth you call them
on the phone and they'll give you the
advice you're looking for and their free
e-report the top 14 ketogenic foods with
every order hey pass me some of that uh
yeah you can put some in my coffee this
stuff is really stuff really good
yeah that's what i've been doing
basically for breakfast just uh heavy
cream and keto powder with my coffee
so again go to eatrightandfeelwell.com
special shout out to biotrust anybody
who's willing to sponsor the shows that
we do considering in the you know we're
in age of canceled culture and all stuff
eternally grateful for that support
eatrightandfeelwell.com but don't forget
go to timcast.com you can support our
work our work directly as a member you
are helping to employ all of our
journalists our fact checkers and you
will also get access to exclusive
members only segments of the tim cast
irl podcast we will have one of those
members only podcasts up around 11 or so
pm
and we got some really nasty stories
it's like
youtube does not appreciate so this is
this is where we we call you know the
uncensored because we talk about very
adult issues we often swear a whole lot
and this show we try to keep it
family-friendly so if you want to get
the un un family friendly version go to
timcast.com become a member help support
our work but now
let's get into that news here's the
story from the daily mail
tuning out viewership at scandal played
cnn plummets by as much as 90 percent
from last year in both overall audience
and in their advertiser coveted 25 to 54
demographic this i'm i'm smiling right
now or i'm holding back laughing to be
honest they say the network averaged
just for 548 000 viewers during the week
of january 3rd a precipitous drop from
the nearly 2.7 million viewers from the
same week in 2021.
cnn in the last year has been plagued by
high profile scandals critics have
slammed networks network boss jeff
zucker over the declining ratings
is where it gets crazy let me let me
read this where's that where's that good
number i want to see here we go
cnn saw an 86 percent decline in the
much desirable 25 to 54 demo with a
paltry
113 thousand uh 113 000 tuned in last
week compared to the 822 000 scene and
averaged a year ago wow if you want to
understand understand how bad that is
you can just look at
our videos and they'll have 350 to 500
000 views that doesn't show you the live
viewer count on these shows which is
often around 250 000 people who watch
live i don't youtube does this weird
system where they're separated there's
different analytics for the live stream
versus the the people watching the vod
version but i will just tell you our
audience is like 90
key demographic so if we're getting half
a million people per night and cnn's
getting none
well i guess it's good news the
narrative is breaking the matrix is
shattering people are starting to to get
away from corporate press bs
and while that sounds really good i
still have to point out cnn gets propped
up on youtube and still gets a hundred
million views per month yeah this also
is a little
you know
an extreme title they say as much as 90
because they're talking about an
election year oh no no they're not
talking about 2021 but they're they're
comparing it to 2020 after the election
oh right right right right so like that
was a hot news period those few weeks
before january 20th you know so to
compare it to that oh no no no no no no
i'm sorry i'm sorry i gotta correct you
sorry it is this week being compared to
2021
so it is fair to say january of 2021 was
a code news warped my mind dude i
thought the election was last year yeah
that's crazy
because you've been waiting biden's been
president for two years tell me that
this is not right yeah yeah in a month
biden came in 2021 yeah yeah all right
i'm out of a time warp yeah a year ago
okay so yeah yeah
that week you need to change your
sleeping habits
that's another story you might be right
but who would have thought you know
watching the deep state television is
not popular who would have thunk it and
and again we also have to understand
that overall
uh you know when it comes to cable
television their viewership has been
going down dramatically but i don't
think cnn has been doing themselves any
favors especially with their lineups
especially with their scandals
especially with lube and tubin the
vanderbilt creepy como and and telling
people not to read the wikileaks because
it was illegal telling people that that
there was definitely russian collusion
obsessing about donald trump non-stop
when he had two scoops of ice cream i
mean come on i i can't believe this is
not surprising that they lost 90 of
their viewership i'm surprised they
didn't lose all of their viewership to
be completely honest well from what i've
been seeing they no longer have the
airport contract but they're still in
hotels
oh yeah there won't be zero i haven't
read your book yet but in the book did
you follow cnn at all and go deep on
them yeah the book opens with a scene at
cnn with don lemon and kirsten powers
and they're sitting there talking about
um how donald trump winning is proof of
the enduring and unabated white
supremacy in america
and you know they're sitting there these
two people who are worth you know 10
million dollars and 25 million dollars a
piece and sneering and looking down
their nose at a president's supporters a
president who won 67 percent of whites
without a college degree right and to me
that was sort of the opening primal
scene because i think a lot of what
we're seeing here
it looks like it's about politics it
sometimes looks like it's about race but
actually it's about class can you can
you uh say the name of your book one
more time for people who are sure
it's called i don't know why i can't say
it without doing this bad news how woke
media is undermining democracy yes yes
um yeah and basically what happened over
the course of the 20th century was
journalism went from being a blue-collar
job to being the provenance of you know
the most highly educated very affluent
top 10 elites and tim i think you
represent what journalism used to be
like the fathers of american journalism
they were populist they were guys who
dropped out of high school or didn't go
to high school working class guys who
had to really struggle who then went out
to the people to report and crucially
felt a deep sense of responsibility
to those people to to be responsive to
them to give them what they were asking
for and to treat them with respect and
that's been your career in journalism
and that's the opposite of what we see
in places like cnn in the new york times
i disagree with you because i would say
you know a vanderbilt anderson cooper
definitely has more of a sense of
reality and more of a humbleness to him
than any of other peasants out there and
clearly his his upbringing
you know his his affluence has brought
him to be more knowledgeable and more
special than all of us yeah but i i
wonder if it's not so much about uh
upbringing or anything luke and i have
had very different actually maybe even
sort of similar you know in some ways
luke coming from poland a family that
dealt with the soviet-era communist
stuff in poland and coming to the united
states and it is populism i think it's
also
i i want to be left alone
right i don't want i don't want anyone
to be my boss i don't want to have a
boss i don't want to be anyone's boss
and here we are somehow of a company
with employees
but uh my attitude towards the news is
i'll just tell you and you do your thing
because i look at it this way
if i got a neighbor
i don't want to be micromanaging and
dealing with all of his problems i want
to be able to be like a guy the reason
why you've got this problem here with
this you know sewage leak is because you
did these things fix it and leave me
alone
whereas you've got a lot of people who
seem to think
these journalists particularly and and
these the establishment uh political
class
let me just be in control of everyone's
lives so i so it you know it's easier
that way like you know bloomberg wants
to put a tax on sugary drinks that you
can't buy them i don't have anything to
do if you want to drink sugar drinks you
go ahead and do it i don't care i'll
tell you it's bad for you and then you
can do whatever you want so i think that
right there there's a meme
where it shows a bunch of people and
they're all yelling and then it shows
someone at a podium and the journalist
has got us back to the podium and he's
bull horning at the crowd repeating what
the podium says and then it says the way
journal and it's like that's how
journalism is how it's supposed to be is
the guy with the bullhorn standing in
front of the people yelling at the guy
with the podium that's the way i kind of
see it you know um but what you're
describing is contempt right my book is
about contempt it's about how the media
which is supposed to be on the side of
the little guy fighting for the little
guy against the guy at the podium right
became on the side of the guy at the
podium because they go to the same
schools as millionaires and billionaires
and they live in the same neighborhoods
as people at the top of the food chain
and politicians and their kids go to the
same schools as all these other elites
they are now on the side of power and
they have immense amounts of contempt
for the working class just dripping off
of them i gotta say it my favorite
moments of the donald trump election
cycle in 2015 was when he ordered that
30 a 30-day dry age steak well done with
ketchup
and i could see it the moment he did it
totally regular working class middle
americans whatever they go to the
grocery store they can't afford filet
mignon so they get a t-bone they cook it
through and put ketchup on it because
that's the way to make it taste better
trump knows this and he was trying to
have these people look at him and be
like that's how i do it and the media
laughed and they mocked him and talked
about how how stupid and uncouth he was
and it just made regular people hate the
media they're like you're not making fun
of him you're making fun of me i'm poor
i can't afford your expensive trash with
your fancy garlic and volcanic salt
wagyu beef or whatever like yeah
i mean the way i say it maybe you would
see it a little bit differently but i
kind of want to ping off your
perspective because being in the digital
world being at some of these events i
see two class of journalists there's one
class that's kind of drug addicted with
substance abuse problems and another
class that's the kind of snobby
limousine liberals that think that
they're better and know better what's
for everyone else i i don't see a
distinction and very rarely do i see
anyone kind of in the middle of that or
anyone outside of those two categories
would you agree or disagree
well i'll just give you some statistics
so 92 percent of journalists in america
today have a college degree which is
obscene because you can't teach
journalism you know you can't teach
someone to do what you do to be a good
listener to ask the right questions to
question your own biases to be willing
to be wrong you can well they're not
when they're three years old
a person learns a lot of these skills
when they're very young
so you take someone who's you know been
brought up in a in a family that's well
off maybe got help at their at their you
know new york condominium put them in
college and then think they're going to
be able to listen and it's not going to
happen i went to college for journalism
for a year and then switched over to
theater but in the journalism thing i
got an opportunity to do my college tv
station i did like sports for the tv
station and special reporting and i also
learned how to copyright copy edit that
was so they were teaching me structure
but not ethics there was no mention ever
of ethics right
so 92 have a college degree the majority
have a graduate degree which is a purely
vanity degree that costs 70 thousand
dollars to become a journalist in
america today you have to be able to
take a starting salary of 30 000 a year
but 75 of those jobs are on the coast
and the most expensive american cities
which means you have to come from money
essentially like everyone you see on
your tv everyone you read in the new
york times these people come from money
they are overeducated and they look down
on you and i think that's what we're
seeing is the american people are too
smart for this garbage they are too
smart for it and they're tuning it out i
love it so much
uh
i grew up in a uh you know
rough-and-tumble kind of uh neighborhood
in life luke had his you know south
bronx and and pulling all that stuff so
i think
south brooklyn yeah sorry brooklyn that
works um so i think there's certainly
something to like witnessing real life
and hardship
i i have contempt for the elites who
think they're smarter and better than
everyone else when they're just people
i know a lot of people and i've met a
lot of people in my life who are wealthy
and humble and libertarian and be like
i'm never gonna try and look i i've got
you know thing going for me i'm gonna
let you do your thing because i don't
want to press and i respect that but
there are a lot of people who are like
well my family knows better and i'm
better and there's nothing more
satisfying than to see snooty elites
with their fancy degrees who think
they're smarter and better than everyone
fail when they try to go into these news
organizations to tell people how to live
what to do why they're smarter than you
and then they can't figure out why
they're laden with debt why they're
struggling to find work but they still
think they're smarter and you know what
i just sit back and say if you weren't
such an [ __ ] maybe i'd have some
sympathy for you and to all and to all
of the people
i've met who've got college degrees
because they were told to do it and got
massive student debt and are nice and
realistic and willing to listen i have
nothing but respect for them but there
is this class of people that enters
media where they just
the way they prove themselves is to get
a job in the media so that they can get
be given access to a platform that they
don't deserve that they've not proven
with merit and then yell at you and talk
about how much better they are than you
and how you're a bigot and you're racist
and you voted for donald trump well
certainly you're a white supremacist
when in reality it's probably some dude
who's like i lost my job
my kids need food donald trump says he's
gonna bring my factory back and that was
it and they they don't want to listen to
those people they're just stupid learn
to code why don't you learn to code and
then when you speak up and say why don't
you learn to code when they lose their
jobs twitter bans you for it i can't
stand these people they're they're
elites they're pompous they think
they're better than everybody
so let me ask you this maybe you don't
want to answer this but when you got to
vice
were you suddenly surrounded by exactly
that type of person
mostly uh
in 2013
so i actually
met the vice people in 2011 after
occupied and it was vice was a hole in
the wall man
they apparently like took over an old
skate shop or something i don't know the
history of that building
it was cool and that's why i liked them
and that's why when i started saying
okay now i'm going to take my skills and
bring it to actual news i went to vice
because
it was
punk rock they were they were edgy they
were non-partisan the ceo of vice went
on colbert and he was like look we don't
we don't damn we're not democrat we're
not republican we're just storytellers
we're here to talk about what we see and
i was like thank you i don't care about
this stuff
but when i get in i got in around the
time it started turning into that and
it's because they got money murdock came
in he gave him 70 million dollars then i
watched one by one the core crew of vice
get fired abruptly and replaced with a
new york media establishment you know
individual fresh out of college with the
rolodex
some people went on i'm gonna go work
for bloomberg or they came from
bloomberg and then all of a sudden
things just started changing and i was
just like
it's not the scrappy edgy hole in the
wall in williamsburg williamsburg was a
dirt hole in new york it's probably why
they set up there it was cheaper to be
in new york and it was cheap
well they helped gentrify the area they
bring in all this hipster youth and then
all of a sudden it's virtue signaling
hipsters who think they're smarter than
you and they know it
so i left and then four i i went to a
disney company
and uh
not better yeah so they promised it
wasn't going to be woke they're like
we're going to be nice vice we're going
to be like real you know uh fusion had a
show about drug wars it was actually
called drug wars and they tracked like
federalism and government agents going
after the cartels and stuff and i was
like wow that's cool stuff and then
within six to eight months they were
like new editor-in-chief we're going
woke everything we're gonna do is gonna
be about wokeness and i'm like what year
was that 2014. yeah that track well so
in 2014 is when i started and then it
was mid 2015 early to mid 2015 where
they were like
they they they what i think happened was
they had one video about a transgender
child that got a huge it got a huge it
was a huge hit it got them like a
hundred thousand views and that was one
of their first videos that actually got
traffic and then all of a sudden they
were like that's it
that's what young people want what i
absolutely love about this is when you
have these middle-aged marketing white
dudes
who don't know anything about what's
going on
and so they were asked like what's 2016
going to look like for fusion and the
guy goes gender
and they're like and what does that mean
he goes we're just going to be heavily
focused on gender
no seriously and people were like i i
don't know what that means do you know
what you're saying
they got a few a few big videos and they
decided that was their audience and then
i said look man i luke and i we went to
fukushima while i worked there i'm like
i go on the ground to like these
conflict in crisis situations and film
that and explore it
what am i gonna do and so they tried to
do some stuff like uh i went to a
weapons expo and we looked at all the
different like riot control weapons that
pertain to like the protest movement and
we tested them out but that video
footage never made it out there with me
and tim literally have getting here
sitting in a chair testing who's going
to sit there the longest with this crazy
military guy being like okay now we're
going to do this i don't like okay we
got taser we got tasered too do you
remember the tasering i think it's taser
do you guys taste it the stomach there's
a video was it me or you you i think
it's so i think i got tasered wait where
did you wake up he didn't have he didn't
have the gun
the firing one he had the one that you
have to put towards your body i think it
was only like 20 000 volts but i think
yeah yeah yeah he hit me yeah it was me
yeah i remember getting tasered the
issue was
no longer the video never made it out to
the general public this is what i was
sleeping on like tim pulls couches when
he was working for disney i'll tell you
why i'll tell you why so i go to the
higher ups and i and and they were
talking we met this guy he was one of
their specialists in um weapons training
and stuff and it turned out i don't want
to say too much but this is a guy of
experience to say the least
international law enforcement government
stuff and so i said can you talk to us
about
strategies for riot control he's like
yes i can and then i said we need to go
somewhere where we can test all this
stuff out is there maybe a field
somewhere you know we're in miami
there's a lot of farmland and they were
like you got it and i said let's have
this guy he he he couldn't he was like
people can't know who i am because of
the work i've done i work behind the
scenes i said wear a mask well if you
wear a mask well if you do all this
stuff we'll go in the middle of nowhere
so they they give us the address and
we're driving there and i see they're
like okay we're here and i'm looking
around i'm like this can't be right
we're like a parking lot across the
street from a mcdonald's there's people
everywhere and like no this is it and it
was a garage and the guy comes out and
i'm like you expect us to let off tear
gas and flashbangs in a parking lot of a
mcdonald's yeah seriously and that's
what they did
and i was like dude i don't want to have
anything to do with this man you're
crazy they brought out a bunch of crazy
equipment that made everything look
really nice the fbi showed up oh my god
they did yes remember i i put like an
instagram story or snapchat story back
then and then the fbi showed up there
and then they're like what's going on
here uh and then the guy explained it
and then they went away oh wow yeah i
was i was on the phone actually i was on
the phone like being like what are you
guys what do you think this was going to
be like
we're supposed to be looking at rubber
bullets foam rounds tear gas and we're
in an urban parking lot there's people
everywhere we can't do this and they
were like what's the problem and i was
like you want to take responsibility for
someone getting tear gas i'm not gonna i
don't want to be involved in that so
yeah never made it to tv yes that's
hilarious so there's footage out there
of me getting tasered that's denied to
everyone
i'm disappointed
but that timeline makes a lot of sense
because um the great awokening in the
media happened it started it had a very
so sociologists have found that had like
a very specific starting point which was
around 2011 2012 when the new york times
erected its paywall not coincidentally
that's when you started to see woke
terminology start to just absolutely
skyrocket across the major mainstream
liberal news media so sociologists have
literally trawled the archives of the
new york times and the washington post
and npr and the atlantic and all these
outlets and they found that words like
oppression marginalization the word
people of color near the word oppression
or marginalization white privilege it's
like a hockey stick like they were kind
of like this until 2011 to them they
started to totally skyrocket and what
happened in 2015
was
white liberals
their their opinion as it was polled by
sociologists so public opinion among
white liberals
started to outpace public opinion of
blacks and latinos in terms of how
radical it was on issues of race so that
that impact of the skyrocketing of the
use of these terms in the liberal media
by three years later four years later by
2015 it had this huge impact on public
opinion of white liberals to where they
became much more extreme in their views
on race than blacks and latinos and
started using this very academic
language and that's kind of where the
great awokening started did you see that
one study that showed liberals white
progressives are the only uh racial
group in the united states with an
out-group preference yes so what that
means is uh
people who are hispanic or latino
slightly tend to prefer being around
people who are hispanic or latino black
people slightly it's like i think you
know 18 of 100 so it's like it's low but
it exists
white conservatives slightly prefer to
be around white conservatives and
liberals prefer not to be around white
people
did you know this is weird yeah there's
also a correlation with the graph that
you were mentioning that i've been
seeing online with of course occupy wall
street and some people theorizing that
this was the corporate media's response
towards people going against the big
banks going against the big institutions
that have failed them going against the
banker bailouts that have redistributed
wealth to the very rich taken away from
the very poor and
from from what i'm seeing it's a
perspective of holy crap people are
catching on to what we're doing we need
to divide and conquer them therefore
let's inject this language which will
help create do that do you think that
that that is a possible theory okay so
i'll give you a less
conspiratorial version and then you'll
tell me if you find it convincing enough
to abandon the more delicious
conspiratorial version which i could
totally see why that's like a satisfying
way to think about it and i totally
agree that this great awokening moral
panic about race is a distraction from
the real divide in america which is the
disgusting levels of income inequality
and the class divide so i agree with
that part of it i do personally think
from a
from the point of view of the news media
this was much more about the digital
revolution in terms of media i think it
coincided with the new york times
erecting its paywall because what they
started to do was what all of us in
digital media do which is be able to
track
what terms people clicked on what terms
made them close the browser you know
what words made them share things what
words made them engage online and of
course engagement is the big measure of
success for digital media and so i think
that there's a much less kind of
big picture there's just like a profit
margin to where journalists have always
been more liberal than americans at
large but here you had their corporation
saying no no chase that you know racial
liberalism because our audience likes it
i would even go just a little bit
further and say maybe the algorithms
that favor that were also manipulated
because of that larger possible
conspiracy but same same reason we could
also live in a reality where both were
true at the same time yeah well no look
look look so so i wasn't convincing
enough to be no you're right it could be
no no i'm getting i'm getting i'm
kidding
luke's wrong you're right
because i've talked about this too
it's not just the media organizations
we're making money that facebook was as
well yes so facebook
incentivized in their algorithms terms
like these now i'm not saying i know for
a fact they literally said we want this
to appear more
but if the algorithm favors if the
algorithm is simply designed if someone
clicked something show it more
then terms that made people angry
injustice were more likely to be shared
so this did a couple things
all of a sudden we saw the rise of the
digital blog we saw the huffington post
buzzfeed
when uh as i often explained for those
who have heard it forgive me but for
those who haven't
if you read an article that says police
are racist you'll get x views
if you write an article saying police
are sexist you'll get y views but if you
read an article saying police are sexist
and racist those two keywords gives you
an exponential boost you'll get a bonus
to the amount of traffic because when an
article gets a substantial amount of
play the algorithm boosts it more so now
that you're hitting two different
communities the anti-racism and the
anti-sexism community facebook says
oh wow this one got a hundred thousand
show it to another twenty thousand see
what happens
nothing this one got a hundred thousand
do the same thing but when this article
gets two hundred thousand whoa show it
to another hundred thousand keep showing
it that one's getting way more traffic
than normal
so the combination of terms gave rise to
intersectionality which was a big
component in the precursor of the
culture war
which then resulted in a lot of this you
know wokeness but another really obvious
component
you're familiar with gamergate yes so i
can't tell you everything about
gamergate now now nearly 10 almost 10
years on what i can say is
a a video game publication accusing a
person of being racist makes no sense
but what happens is if you are tasked
hey we're going to make a video game
website what can you really write about
well uh some of these sites would be
like okay a new game came out we got a
new zelda game um let's write all the
ticks and all the tricks and tips all of
the items you can get and then what and
then what the next day you come into
work and the editor goes what are you
going to write about well i just
finished writing about the zelda game
and they're like we need articles i
don't care what's going on uh
this developer tweeted the joke that's
offensive write it up and then all of a
sudden they found the easiest way to get
traffic was
can we accuse someone of being a bad
person and it somehow relates to video
games and then all of a sudden you have
these these outlets being like if we are
going to keep writing news every single
day we need an angle and that's a result
of dying
but just really dying art form um
because video game gameplay footage on
youtube took over so now if you want to
watch gameplay review you don't read
about it you watch it on tv and they
were just scraping for life there's an
important question to answer here does
the algorithm run us or do we run the
algorithm so it's like a did the chicken
come or the egg
i would argue that there are people tied
into a lot of these bigger big tech
social media companies that are doing
social human experimentation uh are
doing uh psychological experiments just
like facebook has done and and knowingly
conducted controlling our emotions and i
think there is even a bigger profit
motive to make someone feel lonely to
feel sad to feel depressed and i think
there is a correlation between our
mental health decline and of course the
onset and prominence of big tech social
media so i i would say that i believe
that
both could be true but i think what is
more prevalent is the algorithm uh
running us that's my perspective that's
how i see it from my experiences you see
it differently i agree with you yeah
that's true
it's not
we do have the article this is from the
guardian facebook sorry almost for
secret psychological experiment on users
they've been doing this they're probably
still doing it facebook knows when you
poop but what happens is
facebook youtube twitter whoever makes
an algorithm they're aiming for an
outcome they can't program for this is
the danger of i think one of the big
dangers of ai but so youtube says
we want content on youtube that is long
form with a high retention rate that
hits issues subject matter people like
how do we do that okay if someone clicks
the video that's a good sign if someone
watches for a long time that's a good
sign and then we'll show everybody the
same words that keep getting clicked
what happens
youtube starts promoting hitler doing
tai chi with the incredible hulk singing
nursery rhymes yes because it was babies
who watched the most and just watched
100 of videos because they don't touch
anything
this is what happens when a human
programs an algorithm and then lets it
run the algorithm goes wild so we ended
up like everything we're seeing right
now rachel maddow right
russia russia russia russia it's called
audience capture
rachel maddow can't admit she was wrong
about it so she just elides the
controversy she ignores it now she's
coming out and claiming that republicans
forged electoral documents
the reality is
as is typical with any contentious
election republican electors in 20 and
2020
filled out their uh electoral slates
sent them to the government that's it
the same thing happened in 1960 with
hawaii nixon and kennedy well rachel
maddow could tell you the truth
but then she won't get traffic then her
audience won't like what she has to say
so she just plays into that narrative
humans become servants to the algorithm
after the algorithm chooses nonsense to
be popular the human plays along with it
and pushes that same garbage okay so i
think i disagree with you guys i think
that the well okay from the point of
view that i have which is the point of
view of elite media or rather mainstream
you know legacy media to me it seems
like
they have very much abandoned the idea
of like mass readership the new york
times is no longer going for a mass
readership they're going for
elite highly educated liberals based on
the subscriber model so now they only
have to satisfy those i think right now
they have seven million we don't
disagree interestingly we're going to
also but i think you can't like the
when you have such a small everybody now
all the liberal outlets including cnn
all these people are going for the same
they all they don't want all americans
watching they want 10 million affluent
liberals like that's and so to like it's
those people are very specific in terms
of what they're looking for we we agree
we're agreeing we're agreeing yeah i'm
saying rachel maddow has a very small
and specific audience that she can't be
true right so she'll say whatever needs
to be said to keep them enthralled but
that's humans that's not facebook well
no what i mean is
someone creates an algorithm the
algorithm then generates a kind of
content that people
get attached to rachel maddow then sees
here's a market share i can take right
based upon the algorithm manipulation so
a better example is black lives matter
and police brutality
videos that generate outrage
get more shares and more interactivity
than anything else and so facebook was
inundated with police brutality videos
police brutality accounts for a
microscopic percentage of all police
interactions
but
they get clicks
so you have a generation of kids this is
the next component outside of the media
making money you had kids who were 15 16
years old
at the dawn of
facebook
they go on facebook
all they see is police brutality over
and over and over again because it was
making money for these companies then by
the time they're out of college they're
22 a few years later it's 2012
2013 and they are hypnotized believing
the entire world is police hunting down
black people so their whole perspective
is warped to an insane degree
rachel maddow and people like her have
found a captive audience who believe in
saying things that they can pander to
right but i have to say specifically on
that example i feel like that one is
very much a double-edged sword like
i don't believe that george floyd's
killers killer would be in prison if not
for the algorithm doing that because
that would not have become a national
story and without it being a national
story would we have had that video would
it have gone that way and so i feel like
there's such a it's such a double edge
but should he be in prison
oh that's there's a divide in this
country between conservatives
there is absolutely really oh we we've
gone over that that story to a great
degree when the story first broke we
were all very much on the side of like
whoa that was really wrong of him to do
and then when the body camera footage
got released we were like wow the media
lied to us about everything noting like
with george floyd yeah like george floyd
was on a speed ball he had high doses of
methamphetamine and what else did he
have nicotine uh caffeine and fentanyl
and he was chewing on a speedball five
drugs yeah but he was strangled to death
i mean yeah technically i think cause of
death was cardiac arrest but that might
have been due to asphyxiation no it
wasn't no there were two um autopsies
that came out the family's autopsy said
it was strangulation and then the state
coroner said it was no but i watched the
whole trial and it was very clear that
it was um strangulation well i mean that
wasn't even contested by his lawyer well
it's it's not i'm not trying to get it
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah sorry
i'm down because i'm willing i'm i'm
willing to have the argument you know he
should be you know manslaughter at the
very least but the issue is that um in
there there's there's it's it's not so
clear-cut and you have you have you
probably have the the the more
conservative side of things saying
it's not clear-cut that he should be in
jail uh one example is even in the trial
the use of force expert for the for the
prosecution said that uh chauvin would
have been entitled to use even more
force than he had already used so there
i'm again i'm not saying you're wrong
i'm just saying there were issues where
people see it differently
and so
i actually just pulled up here from
mystateline.com i haven't checked it out
but an autopsy report confirmed george
floyd died from a cardiac arrest which
was quote complicated by law enforcement
subduel um this was the cardiac arrest
was caused by him being strangulated
that's what it said well it says yeah it
was complicated it was caused by
probably complications due to law
enforcement subdued a better example
yeah we just choked him until he had a
heart attack a better example is
probably like kyle rittenhouse
that's a perfect example i'm sure we
totally agree about that that was
disgusting i mean but this is what what
happens when um maybe there's even a
better example than that like
russiagate or what i mentioned with
rachel maddow and claiming republicans
forged documents there's there's a
desperate need to satisfy your
subscriber base
we don't do that
we you know uh we don't we just talk
about what we want to talk about
sometimes people get mad at us i've
criticized people on the right and often
have people yelling at me and i'm like
dude whatever if you think i'm just
gonna pander and then they're like it's
it's really amazing that cancel culture
does exist for everyone it doesn't mean
if you know it's not only on the left
for sure with the rise of subscription
model this is fascinating what is the
future of journalism
if you're i mean how can you keep a
journalistic enterprise afloat and try
and be the fourth estate and criticize
everything and everyone
when you have to have subscribers
that'll leave if you start criticizing
the people they love
yeah so so the new york times right now
91 of its readership are democrats now
that takes a lot of work to get there
for the paper record that's no that's no
easy feat you know like something they
did in the last five years just like cnn
you know in 2012 as recently as 2012
both cnn and fox news had a pr
predominantly working class viewership
they had only 25 of both fox and cnn had
a college degree
over the course of the last you know 10
years or whatever cnn lost half of its
working class audience it's signal to
working class libs
this channel is no longer for you how
did it do that with wokeness because
wokeness is a smoke screen for a class
divide it's being perpetuated by white
liberal elites who are literally lining
their pockets with this stuff
you know to avoid talking about a class
divide that they have benefited from let
me let me show you an example that i
that i talked about earlier today this
is from wishtv.com i believe it's a
indianapolis channel 8.
it is fat shaming
to point out that people who get coveted
and are
who are being hospitalized tend to be
obese
so we have this tweet from i don't know
this person is but melissa cancel
student debt burn
is fat shaming the new cdc government
policy
the the last week of cdc gov tweets has
been awful what did the cdc say
they say
a new cdc mmwr finds that two out of
three children and adolescents
hospitalized for covid had one or more
underlying health conditions most
commonly obesity fewer than one percent
of uh
fewer than one percent eligible for
cova-19 vaccination have been vaccinated
learn more they didn't insult people for
being fat they didn't say it was bad to
be fat they didn't say you're ugly or
you're nasty they simply said here's a
fact
and that was mocked so what we see here
is
i suppose
virtuous virtue signaling perpetuating a
cycle of decay and destruction in this
country so the reality is
if you want to live a longer life if you
want to have a lower chance of going to
the hospital with kovid lose weight
eat better
exercise talk to a medical professional
and a healthy nutrition specialist who
can help you
live better but instead of hearing
things like why not take some vitamin d
and get some sunlight and breathe some
fresh air and get some exercise we hear
everything has to align perfectly with
whatever tribe people find themselves in
this woman it's fat shaming to point out
a fact
well that's that's the tribe they're in
but it's also like look how lovely and
slim she is like the person doing this
like these people like like you know
there's such a hypocrisy there you know
the same thing with like you see this a
lot with marriage right like you see
this sort of liberal culture that's you
know often telling people oh marriage is
an antiquated institution like people
don't have to get married stop shaming
people you know we have to promote all
kinds of family structures and the
people saying that are all you know
affluent highly educated people who are
married who are you know benefiting very
much from marriage from an economic
point of view because marriage has been
very much correlated with higher
earnings and so you have this kind of
like this this this tiny tiny elite that
is impervious to the costs of its bs
right to the cost of saying oh no it's
totally fine to be obese like that'll
never hurt you you know like we have to
respect people's choices to be this way
right or it's not a choice right like
while at the same time they would never
in a million years allow their own
children to live in that way i find it
really really it's it's it's terrible
obesity is definitely a choice in 2003 i
started to get obese so i stopped eating
mcdonald's and drinking coke every day
for lunch and i didn't get obese as a
result some people have a genetic
predisposition some people don't maybe
but it is i don't know fasting is like a
lost art
we know it's true but there's still the
reality of you can't gain weight if you
don't ingest the calories
so it may be more difficult for some
people but people could choose i don't
know i just look at cheesecake and i'm
like gain the weight
they've got they've got hold on there
hold on i've been doing keto cheesecake
is very fatty so it's excellent so long
it's sweetened with allulose yes or
erythritol i don't like erythritol
though the sugar alcohol stuff but we've
got we've got keto cheesecake and it
tastes exactly the same in fact you know
we got some in the green room so uh you
can try definitely
taking them out so
it's really good i got some regular
cheesecake i'm gonna be partaking in
that myself
you know like people like living a
lifestyle that benefits them and their
children and then hoarding the benefits
for themselves with this rhetoric that
sounds like social justice but actually
is sentencing the poor to live much
worse lives that they would never let
their own children live
that's the point and they're just trying
to do it for profit like when you see
these ads like it's okay to be large oh
that would be so much easier that's the
thing is like yuval 11 has this great
quote he's like he's like washington
would be so much easier to navigate if
everyone who showed up was like
i'm going to get all the money and all
the power when actually what happens is
everyone shows up and says i am going to
heal the world i'm going to fix
everything i'm going to make everything
better like they truly this woman truly
believes that fat shaming is worse than
dying of copen you know that's the
things like they really believe it and i
know this because i was once one of them
we'll take take a look at this uh this
image this famous image from cosmo this
is healthy 11 women on why wellness
doesn't have to be one size fits all no
it's not obesity is not healthy but
she's not obese she looks great i think
technically that is obesity no that's
that's near morbid obesity yeah see um
americans have become so desensitized i
get so annoyed
eat a steak eat eat and like dude stop
eating for 18 hours
this woman she looks great she's
probably morbidly obese really yeah
people americans are so desensitized to
what overweight really is you'd be you'd
be surprised like
people who we would describe as chubby
in america are obese this woman is
probably morbidly obese or at least on
the border of not the fattest you've
ever seen and then this woman here
clearly
i i would assume is is morbid obesity
she also looks great to me i mean as a
human i mean
a lot of muscle foreign
well i think it's true it's possible
it's 100 true that one size does not fit
all when it comes to health but i do
have to say that this was actually
probably my biggest red pill when i was
11 years old i looked at what feminism
had to say about the fat acceptance
movement and i was like are you effing
joking that is not going to help women
live longer happier lives if they really
wanted women to live and see their
grandkids they would be promoting being
active finding something that you like
to do like yoga doing something healthy
with yourself there's there's there's so
many negative health uh consequences of
being overweight yeah higher blood
pressure um heart disease heart disease
especially
you know this body i just want to be i
just want to be a joint
i don't see any muscles i'll just be
honest that's just my perspective
but a lot of this is being done in the
guise of helping them like we need to
help them we need to stop fat shaming
them we need to stop making them feel
bad but essentially what they're doing
is hurting these people even more
later down the line because they're not
being real with them they they they fake
caring about them because if they really
did truly care about someone who is
overweight they'd be like okay you know
let's do this let's hit the gym let's
work out let's let's change your diet
let's get away from the gym
like who do you think they have a line
into their brains like nobody's buying
this no like nobody who do you think
they're convincing they're not
convincing anybody they're virtue
signaling people
they want to be known to feel good
actually there's no person who's like
should i go on a diet no i don't have to
because well i would i would disagree
actually i would actually disagree yeah
because these are people of influence
we see we've seen this in a lot of the
corporate press saying
fat shaming is is bad it's okay to
accept your weight it's there's even you
know people giving out um you know
little notes to individuals to their
doctors saying hey don't ask me about my
weight which is absolutely ridiculous
your doctor should know how much you
weigh they should know how much your
weight has changed my favorite one of my
favorite memes is is all the pretty
obese health bureaucrats um
that were deciding on people's health
and and joe rogan made a very kind of
interesting point about this because he
said you know himself i've been working
on my health almost my entire life i've
been hitting the gym i've been i've been
watching what i eat i've been making
sure i take the right supplements i i
make sure i rest and there's someone who
does the complete opposite of that to
telling me what i should be doing for my
health you know that that should be
something we should consider we
shouldn't make it the end-all be-all but
at the end of the day you know tough
love and just being real and honest with
people goes a lot further than just kind
of patronizing them and pretending to
care about them which i think is going
to lead to more harm you know but also
you could go too far with it like every
time i go to la i'm like this is a
godless place like
absolutely pure materiality it's pure
body worship and it's like there's no
spirit at all it's all it's kind of
great and if you look at the fashion
industry they are normalizing
you know women to look like people yeah
and i think a lot of that has to do with
the jeffrey epstein connections but
that's a whole nother thing to even get
into but there's a lot of you know
jean-luc bernay les wexner there's a
whole lot of individuals victoria's
secret that are involved in portraying
this image of perfection of of these
like girls who are way too young who
look like little boys that that's that's
something that needs to be addressed and
i i do agree with you that's also
another issue that should be talked
about should be addressed just as the
same as this one because it's it's in
the same realm of providing an image
that is absolutely unfair and skews
people's minds to what the reality of
our of our real life is and so do
instagram filters they have a huge
negative consequence for people's mental
health because they get this image
portrayed that everyone's perfect they
don't have any wrinkles they have the
perfect uh bosoms and the perfect uh
glass shape of wine of whatever they
want to describe themselves hourglass
who knows now
[Music]
that's what the soundtrack is
yeah hey look what we were just looking
at just a few moments ago here tell me
i'm not wrong two white wine glasses
upside down yeah there you go there you
go that makes sense thank you ian for
saving me so
the main issue i was trying to get to is
we have a definitive fact that i think
the cdc said 30 of people hospitalized
for covet are obese yes we then have
these virtue signaling media types
saying you're fat shaming by telling
people that yeah it's going to get
people killed yeah
if i could speak to this just because i
have struggled with my weight throughout
my life as people can probably tell i'm
struggling with it again i'm getting a
little chubby as chat likes to point out
oh my god why are you talking so here's
the deal i am concerned the standards
here are way too hard no it's nice i
just know how i used to look and how i
looked before that so i'm like trying to
get up get back on target with my health
and it's it's interesting to me and
horrifying to watch compassion taking
the place of factual observation because
i understand wanting everyone to feel
like they look beautiful i completely
understand as a woman 100
very i i feel deeply that everyone
should understand that they are unique
individuals and have like this unique
perspective in life but when it comes to
helping people live their best lives
their longest lives and get the most out
of life i think it's essential to point
out the things that are dangerous and
i'm very sorry that health has become so
emotionally oriented because it's very
very important for people to live their
fullest lives and to be their best
selves to have an understanding that it
feels good to work out that it feels
great to see yourself get more flexible
and stronger that it's really key to
living a better and stronger life and
with the covet thing i think this should
be a turning point in the american
understanding of our own weight as such
a key component of what happens to us in
the hospital
we've disconnected from that we think
that what we eat has nothing to do with
how
we live and how we experience life but
yeah when we start looking at the larger
impacts from the sugar industry and the
factory food industry there's a lot to
unpack there with what is happening to
our health right now that definitely
deserves a real discussion and i think
they're preventing it from happening
yeah for sure when michelle obama got
into office i should say when barack got
in she started the let's move campaign
which was basically let's move and cut
sugar out of our diets everyone yeah and
then a couple weeks went by radio
silence all of a sudden the sugar
industry is part of the white house
group and it changes into an exercise
campaign let's get up and move but what
they're telling people is you can eat
crappy food and then burn off the
calories and you'll be back to zero
that's not how it works you don't if you
if you can't drink diet coke and then
work out and expect to be healthy you
can't put that stuff in your body that
you don't put poison in your body and
this industry like the tobacco industry
has commercials on tv peddling it to
kids this addictive substance sucrose
like
there's some value to it for sure but
it's a drug we gotta treat it like a
drug sugar's a drug so eric adams who's
new york's new mayor who's uh pretty
great um he has this he's a vegan and he
became a vegan because he got diabetes
and he started to lose his vision and
apparently as soon as he became a vegan
three weeks later it all came back and
all the symptoms started reversing
themselves and he pushes veganism as a
kind of racial justice thing because he
says look at the foods that our
community is consuming these are like
foods that we had to learn how to make
because of slavery and because we were
only given scraps but now it's keeping
us enslaved and it's harming our bodies
and we have to have this he has like a
whole metaphor for it and it's it's very
cool but i tend to think of the obesity
epidemic very much along the lines of
like the deaths of despair like from
alcoholism and opioid addiction and
overdose and and um suicide like it's
it's like it's happening among the lower
classes it's happening among the poor
and to me it signals like a kind of
hopelessness of giving up a sign of like
a spiritual dearth and a lack of
connection to to the nation like an
inability to see yourself as an active
participant in building up the nation
because it comes back to economics you
know the offshoring of these great jobs
like downward mobility of the working
class where you no longer see your life
as being on an upward trajectory let's
talk about the uh the paradox of
anti-racism
these woke people say that they are
anti-racists but as we know according to
ebermex candy
anti-racism means actively participating
in discrimination
geekwire writes trulia to drop
neighborhood crime data from home
listings after redfin speaks out against
practice you're going to love this one
they say
given the long history of redlining and
racist housing covenants in the united
states there's too great a risk of this
inaccuracy reinforcing racial bias
christian taubman redfin's chief growth
officer wrote in december 13th post we
believe that redfin and all real estate
sites should not show neighborhood crime
data
there is something profoundly racist
about taking down
crime data and saying it's because it's
racist isn't it paradoxical disgusting
because the implication of course is
that black people
right don't also want to know
where crime is
so they could avoid it right it's so
disgusting
yeah i guess they think
it's it's like they have this
everyone should experience all of the
crime that way no one it's not one group
that does yeah equality everyone suffers
is that so disgusting the erasure of the
victims of crime
like the it's because it embarrasses
white liberals that the perpetrators of
these violent crimes are people of color
that embarrasses them right because it
doesn't fit with the anti-racism where
black people are the oppressed and white
people are the oppressors they are
willing to erase the victims of these
crimes children being gunned down in
their neighborhoods every day and no one
will talk about it the issue with with
uh uh crime in big city and big cities
and in this country is always poverty
you take a look at impoverished white
neighborhoods you'll see a high level of
crime you take a look at black
neighborhoods and published high levels
of crime and what they do is they put a
racial component on it which makes
everyone immediately assume the crime is
race-based
it's a class issue that's my big problem
i take with with wokeness it's basically
it's a scapegoat for the wealthy elites
as you mentioned is a class issue but
they disguise it and it makes these
liberals feel good without having to
actually change anything they're not
going to move from their white enclaves
they're just going to pretend like
they're doing something by removing the
crime stats from from their websites
meanwhile they all know where they're
living they all know where they come
from they all know what they want to do
and how they want to do it
anti-racism is very racist yes and chloe
valderrae i believe said very
plaintively called it um
counter dependence so you can have a
codependent relationship with racism
where you're like blatantly racist and
scream at people like you're worse than
me but having a counter dependence on
racism is also racist
trying to trying to use racism to combat
racism because you hate racism and
you'll use you'll go to any lengths to
stop racism and including be racist but
it makes no sense a lot of this and it
is racist for what reason does redfin or
trulia have to remove crime data this is
just a virtue signal and this data isn't
going away just because they're not
putting this filter on top of the map
anymore they have the data their rich
allies have the data the people who want
it will get it the normal people will
not have it and this that's disgusting
that's the hypocrisy you're talking
about i'll tell you exactly why i can't
stand
the democratic party and overwhelmingly
the establishment left
they are willing to
ignore reality for the sake of tribe
certainly the trump supporters have that
element too but they're not in power
they don't control cultural institutions
and i just look at um
covet data i take a look at the vaccine
mandates the mask mandates i take a look
at how they virtually signal this way i
take a look at how they tell people we
want to just black lives matter they
want to disrupt the nuclear family even
though we know the nuclear family is a
huge component really it's related to
success
and a better living
when it comes to
all of these policies rich people are
exempt they're always exempt rich person
wants crime data they simply go to a
service and they pay the money and they
get it right and if you if you're making
millions of dollars what do you care
about spending a thousand bucks on crime
data but they'll remove it for you the
average american
when it comes to vaccine mandates and
mass mandates rich people don't got to
worry about it when it comes to air
travel oh no everybody's got to wear
their mask they want to fly in planes
joe biden says maybe we'll do a vaccine
mandate for air travel the rich person
says let's take private why do i care
it's always something negative for the
poor and the working class
i just you know i take a look at going
back to the trump years
you had americans suffering
these small towns were being gut and
destroyed by neoliberal policy sending
factories overseas
and then when these people
said we need help and many of them
wanted bernie sanders hillary clinton
wins they say okay we'll take trump the
response from the elites is you're all
racists and you're perpetuating white
supremacy and and this is where we are
today the the aftermath of all this fake
virtue signaling garbage yeah this
article reminds me it's kind of similar
to what happened on the view in 2015
when we had uh kelly osbourne said we
can't kick the latinos up because who's
going to clean our toilets
so this is real she said that on air on
national television and when you look at
a lot of these kind of locust when you
look at a lot of these kind of
anti-racist apologists
many times these individuals are
the biggest racists themselves because
they believe that they're better than
other people and that they need to help
them because they're so much better
in in all circumstances than than other
people because of their skin color that
that viewpoint is absolutely absurd and
it's it's white nighting to the absurd
levels this explains the white
progressive so well
authoritarian elitist and racist all at
once
but guilty about it
i i i think you know i i was talking to
someone i worked in la for a little bit
i lived there for a little bit and
people were telling me that celebrities
are really scared they're really
superstitious so they donate a lot of
money to various causes because they're
worried about karma you know they do
this movie they make millions of dollars
and they feel bad that they're living
this way so they give money away this is
kind of the same thing
they're i think i think a better way to
explain it is warren buffett when he
said i can't remember exactly what
happened with this but he was like we
should do a pledge to give away half our
money or something you remember that
luke uh
i remember that yeah and i i don't think
it had anything to do with him actually
caring i think it had to do with him
hedging his bet that there was going to
be a class war and people were not going
to tolerate his wealth so he's like i'm
giving stuff away
so when i see this stuff
these are white supremacists with guilty
consciences these these liberals these
progressives they're deeply racist
individuals they push deeply racist
policies they've actively tried to get
civil rights legislation repealed in
california which proposition was that
where they tried to repeal from their
california constitution the civil rights
provision no joke they tried to remove
that because they said well once we get
rid of it then we can help the poor
minorities by giving them preferential
treatment and i was talking to a friend
of mine who's in la celebrity woke
whatever and she was advocating for this
saying we need this proposition it was
they called it the affirmative action
proposition that by removing the
non-discriminate non-discrimination
clause from our constitution we will be
able to help poor minorities go to
school and get better jobs and better
government contracts and so i asked my
friend
what percentage of california is white
what is it like 70 percent can you pull
that up
i think it's upwards of 70 percent and i
said do you think and and what about
like central california and a lot of
these smaller towns what percentage what
percentage white do you think they are
and she's like oh i probably like 99 i
was like yeah do you do you think these
people are all racist you think white
people are racists 71.71
and she's like yeah i think you know
white people are deeply racist and i
said okay so when you take away
the constitutional provision that bars
racial discrimination
and give a 71 white majority the ability
to discriminate do you think they're
going to all of a sudden give up that
power or entrench it
that's what that's what they i think
honestly i'm not so worried about the
small town white you know
majority putting up you know
whites only or anything like that i am
worried about these progressive
hollywood types who will be like oh well
you know why can't we do that they've
already done it in seattle with their
you know they had the um
what did they say diversity uh people of
color room and non-poc room have you
seen these yeah when they set when they
start segregating so forgive me if i
don't trust these activists when they
claim they're doing it for altruistic
reasons dude it's like bill gates really
quickly actually make a reference
because there's an example i could make
here when he said he was going to give
up all of his wealth to charity he
literally doubled his wealth in a few
years so that that's the type of
individual sorry go ahead i just needed
to say i wonder how many times you got
to see a movie where the guy's like
quick give me the ultimate power item
quick quick and then you give it to him
and he's like yeah thank you and he
turns and uses it on you and you're like
dude like
you don't
give that kind of authority to somebody
i i don't really believe that if
california got rid of that provision in
their constitution all of a sudden all
the white people would be like now so a
chance
but that would ultimately eventually
happen in a no no no no no no
what i mean is for my friend to claim
that she's you know she's woken she
believes white people are all racist
right to then want to give the white
majority the power to discriminate
against people based on race makes no
sense
and they won't back away from it her
response to me was yeah well you know
it's the right thing to do and i'm just
like do you actually care about the
logic of helping poor people or is it
just i'm gonna say whatever my tribe
tells me to say so i'm popular
okay but we have two parties in this
country
and one of my big gripes with
republicans is like okay it's true
you're not all white supremacists but
where's your
offer
to fix the remaining problems that we
have with racism like there's nothing
there there's nothing doing you would
think they would be showing up in the
black community and saying hey i'm going
to give you school choice get your kid
into a good school and i'm gonna put the
criminals away so your kid doesn't get
shot on the way to that good school and
they don't show up well so the
republican establishment doesn't but the
populist republicans are starting to do
that we're starting to it's true well so
that's that's right very very slowly and
it's sort of we need we need everybody
to primary every establishment
politician be a democrat or republican
and then we can get some democrats who
say the exact same thing as republicans
say the same thing and because populism
is is the answer regardless of your
economic position i don't care if you're
a laissez-faire populist or a communist
populist if we find key issues we're
going to work together on and then we
can argue about the rest of it excellent
right instead what we have is the
democratic establishment is obsessed
with trump the republican establishment
just obstructs and then we get we get
nowhere as as you know americans who are
trying to actually solve our problems to
live better lives
this is why i think one of the reasons
trump wins at the very least trump was
like i'm going to bring your factories
back i'm going to bring your jobs back
i'm going to deal with the opioid crisis
i'm going to deal with our border crisis
we're going to end these foreign wars
far from perfect a lot of these things
but hey he didn't start any new wars he
triggered you know he set the timeline
for getting us out of afghanistan he
tried getting us out of syria he did
bring many of our factories back joe
biden comes in everything falls apart
once again i feel like now they're just
the establishment politicians namely the
democrats here's what i see happening
let me slow down
it was always the same with the
democrats and republicans the uniparty
bernie and trump staged an insurgency
from the left and the right bernie is
weak he gave in he caved and now he toes
the line he has been absorbed into the
machine donald trump is a crazy person
who kicked the door in screaming and
took over and now a large portion of the
republican party is controlled by trump
and his supporters there still remains
establishment democrats in control but
they're slowly being weeded out mitch
mcconnell lindsey graham these guys in
my opinion are awful even ted cruz has
proven himself to be weak and feckless
then you do have a lot of populist
republicans who are a little too
aggressive but it's better than the
establishment in my opinion the
democrats have doubled down and
redoubled their efforts the neocons who
were booed out of the party jump sides
to the democratic establishment with
like the lincoln project and now start
towing all of that line so that's that's
it the unit party is in the democrats
they are extracting as much as they can
from this country as the ship is sinking
mitch mcconnell his whole attitude is
well i'm gonna stand here and do nothing
and be a speed bump while the democrats
are like the only thing you should care
about is donald trump then nancy posey
goes buy more stocks as i change the
laws they don't i don't believe any one
of these politicians
save a small handful
actually care about making this country
better i think for the most part they
all see it as what can i do
to ensure my family's wealth and success
because the country is collapsing that's
what i see across the board so my hope
now is that come the primaries people go
to the republican party and they vote
out every single one of these
established republicans all of the and
then you get some working class
individuals
american populists and the same thing
happens to the democratic party i hope
the democrats get some
you know i i it doesn't really fly on
the left but moderate working-class
populist center-left individuals to get
rid of the democratic establishment
corporatist crony garbage and the woke
trash and then the republicans needed
the same thing to the neocon war hawks
and corporatist as well
and then repeal the federal reserve act
of 1913. yeah otherwise we're headed
towards zero
we got to get rid of that stupid
corporation man
i don't know i feel like
decentralization is our best bet
less centralized power at the federal
level you know is our
best opportunity because right now
what's happening is both sides are
trying to fight for supreme power
this is actually the first time in
history that it's been that it's never
been better to create a decentralized
government
what gives you hope tim like what what
is your positive vision like what yeah
i mean uh well gun rights wow uh-huh
that's fantastic gun rights have been
winning across the board and that it
says more than just guns it says that
regular people are are focused on their
individual responsibilities autonomy
yeah autonomy there is still an uh a
semblance of also a lot of people expect
the country to fall apart
but i actually i'm i'm uh it's i
wouldn't say any of this is pessimistic
i think it's fairly optimistic i think
the uh populism is winning
the the
day after day we can see that anybody
who tows the establishment line is is
mocked ruthlessly and insulted and
derided and they're not going to survive
politically adam kinzinger is the best
example he he comes out and he tweets an
insult at jack posobik and i'm just like
bro you you're not going to win a
re-election if you're against jack
posobik jack is a very prominent
conservative personality millions
million plus followers or whatever he
does a big podcast
so you know
i don't the left doesn't like the guy
but on the right
they love him if you're a republican and
you're like i oppose what these people
stand for you may as well leave so these
establishment guys are going to lose i
think the same thing's going to happen
on the democratic side 26 democrats have
announced their retirement because they
know they're done kinzinger announced
his retirement he knows he's done the
establishment is broken it's falling
apart cnn's ratings are in the trash our
ratings are through the roof crowder
glenn greenwald jimmy dore success
across the board for populist
personalities who actually believe in
the working class
i think that's great news
i think the night is always darkest for
the dawn things may get pretty bad i do
think we're on the verge of some major
conflict that's going to happen
national divorce could precipitate some
serious fighting over resources but
ultimately i think
it's going to be
it's going to get a lot better you know
if you believe in the stras how
generational theory then we are in the
fourth turning the period of tumult in
crisis and that means after 2028 things
are going to get really really good and
we're going to have 40 years of growth
and prosperity 20 years of stagnation
and then 20 years of crisis and collapse
again so you know what's marked for 2029
what peak graphine
[Music]
it's a material like um and it's going
to be it's carbon but they figured out
how to make it as a monoatomic layer
just one layer adam thick layer of
carbon i've got amazing properties i've
got using building materials in the 21st
century pure carbon you can get out of
carbon dioxide we can withdraw the
carbon dioxide make buildings out of it
basically
i got this guy a christmas present tim
got me graphing for graphics
um but the market has i did was doing a
lot of research 2018 looking down in
chile to build a company down there to
start producing it and everything was
pointing to 2029 is peak the year that
global society is going to embrace
graphene we we have a button you can't
see it and whenever we feel the
conversations going in circles i press
it and a big thing lights up saying
graphene and it flashes and then it
accuses ian to just also shock it shocks
me it does yeah i'm under my seat in
case my eyes are closed there's a dmt
one for the after show yeah
but to kind of ask you what gives you
hope and to kind of also while you're
you're here i think it's fair to say
that we kind of see the solution as
very differently uh but we agree on the
problem we agree that obviously the
billionaires are controlling too much of
our existence we believe that the banks
have absolutely printed money out of
thin air we believe that we're
controlled by multinational corporations
that call the shots populism has never
been heard by the government is there
hope for us working together somehow
from these different perspectives on
these larger populist ideas do you see
populists from the left and right
potentially ever coming together
i get hope from going around the country
talking to people everywhere who are
working class
who are completely
don't care what their who their
neighbors voted for who are totally
postpartisan
partisanship is a completely elite
phenomenon because elites make money off
of it
and so i get a lot of hope talking to
working-class americans because um
they have hope
and i think that the but but i guess
yeah i still feel stupidly like
i don't know
i don't know how we
how we do it without um
[Music]
i still i'm struggling to have the
vision that you have like to see past
the current moment so i feel a little
bit like i'm still struggling to point
out like to the media itself like hey
you guys are corrupt could you be a
little less cr huh
working class people are human can you
treat them better you know like i feel a
little bit like i'm but i feel super
hopeful about america i love this
country and i i think that it's its
people are getting better and better
every day like i think that we've seen
a huge huge revolution on the right in
terms of how it thinks and talks about
race and how it thinks and talks about
things like police brutality very
recently criminal justice stuff like
that so i get tons of hope from the
unity i see
everywhere except in the elites well
i'll let's talk about hope i have
something that i think could very easily
explain some optimism for everybody you
used to be a woke journalist and you're
no longer
you wrote a book against it yeah so tell
me like how do you how do you find
yourself like how do you end up as a
woke reporter and then one day have an
unwokening and become anti-woke yeah my
deprogramming
it was like a bunch of things you know
like very slow and then all at once but
i definitely had the trump derangement
syndrome it was like in the beginning it
was very hard for me to talk to to i
took it very personally that he won in
that super lame liberal way and um it
you know it took me a while to be able
to admit like oh that's a really good
thing he did and that's a really good
thing he did but um that my
deprogrammings i think it started with
hearing learning about the deaths of
despair and and every night i would turn
on cnn and see the very people
who we had abandoned who were literally
killing themselves because they didn't
see a future for themselves in this
country you know killing themselves
being mocked on cnn being called racist
in the new york times like and i could
that sort of started to really like it
was jarring to me like why are we why do
we not have compassion for them
and then the second thing i would say
was um i read this yale study from 2018
do you guys know about this study no
you're really there's a lot of studies
from here you're really gonna love this
one though you do right yeah maybe um so
and yale did a study in 2018 what they
found was there's a difference between
how white liberals and like
conservatives talk to black latinos i
remember this study great study oh yeah
top tier and um it found that white
liberals dumb down their vocabulary when
they're talking to blacks and latinos
and white conservatives do not and i
remember reading that in 2018 and
thinking to myself this implicates my
entire worldview and i was not ready to
deal with it and i put it aside but i
had this moment where i was like this is
disgusting and everything i think is
caught up in that thing that makes you
dumb down your language you assume a
person of color is less educated than
you is poorer than you and needs your
help and needs your generosity and your
beneficence right that move of like i
instantly recoiled because i i
recognized it and then the third thing
that really i think was like the death
of my trump derangement syndrome was my
rabbi is
just the best person that i know he he's
the kind of person who like in the
winter he walks down the street he sees
a homeless person he starts taking his
clothes off and giving them his coat and
his scarf and everything he's just the
most humble generous person i know and
we were you know having a shabbat meal
once and you know trump came up and he
was like oh i love trump and i was like
excuse me and he was like yeah i love
the guy and i was like you mean you
voted for him you know holding your nose
and he was like no i love him and it was
like that and that's what i tell people
people often ask me like how can i
convince people to not be woke anymore
and what i say is like you can't really
change someone's mind with information
our brains aren't wired that way
what you can do is you can be a person
who is so humble and virtuous or strives
to be virtuous so clearly trying to be a
good person that a person who disagrees
with you can no longer say about
everyone who holds your opinion
you're they're racists they're evil but
i think that's uh uh for liberals it's a
liberal perspective
i think conservatives have a tendency to
be swayed by facts and information
not all of them obviously obviously
there's very emotional people and i
think the left has a tendency a tendency
to be swayed by feelings that's why ben
shapiro tweets interesting facts don't
care about your feelings and gets 50 000
retweets and a million followers and
everyone's cheering for them on the
right and on the left
they're very much driven by you know
care and fairness to sites specifically
jonathan hates research
yes of course conservatives have all six
moral foundations the liberals have two
but when ben shapiro says facts don't
care about your feelings he's kind of
making an emotional statement
you know
but but it's the point stands
and the inverse is true for the left
feelings don't care about your facts but
uh jonathan heights research found that
uh conservatives when they take a moral
foundations test they have a balance of
all these different moral foundations
which is it's a what care fairness
purity authority um freedom yeah there's
one more uh but you're super
anti-authoritarian yeah oh yeah yeah
yeah i mean i think i think
i i think the divide the political
divide is it's obviously not left or
right yeah it's authoritarian versus
anti-authoritarian so if you're someone
who i think liberals have a tendency
towards authoritarianism i hate using
the word liberal because it doesn't mean
that but whatever modern american
leftism is
because they're collectivist and
collectivism is inherently authoritarian
because if the collective which is the
authority decrees you either follow suit
or you're ostracized so if you're
someone who is driven by care and
fairness and that's it you don't care
about loyalty purity authority or
anything like that or freedom liberty is
a is a moral foundation and if you don't
have that well then you don't care if
they're doing vaccine mandates let me
tell you something i think people really
need to understand the left and the
right don't speak the same language
they come out right now in new york city
and they say vaccine mandates work let
me just ask you a very simple question
do you think vaccine mandates work no
why not
well i think they're unconstitutional
well that's not a question of why you
mean do they work at preventing this i
didn't say that i said do they work do
they work and you with no qualifications
no qualifications do you think they work
do i think they work i don't think they
work and why is that well because of
omicron so this is really interesting
because
people on the left know this they know
new york is experiencing a massive surge
in cases but when they say vaccine
mandates work they're not talking about
preventing covid they're talking about
forcing people to adhere to the
collective which is you must get the
vaccine regardless of the outcome
on the right they say vaccine mandates
don't work
because covet is still spreading like
crazy
so that's a really interesting
distinction between the two cultural
definitions
the left today is also deeply
meritocratic not not in the sense of a
real meritocracy but in the sense of
they're deeply careerist and deeply
obsessed with credentials and that's not
meritocracy it's it's it's okay so agree
with you disagree about well it's
authoritarianism it's uh look go getting
getting it getting a college degree
doesn't prove you're a journalist
but it's very individual it's like the
desire to rise above the pack and tell
everybody else what to do and become
famous and be like that to me seems
really individualist like no no no i
mean uh in north korea you want to be a
party member in china you want to be a
party member you want to be a part of
the collective at the highest ranks to
prove your value to the authority
whereas uh on the right you have
tendency towards libertarianism which is
get off my property and leave me alone
right when when someone says go to
college and get a degree they're not
saying get an education they're saying
adhere to the cult adhere to the
authority
you get it's remarkable to me i meet so
many people who are you know i'm going
to go to college and get a degree and
get a job i'm like what is that degree
going to do for your job or what you
want to do nothing
they admit this they say it's a piece of
paper that proves you've done something
millennials my entire life have said
this when i'm like what's the point of
getting a college degree it just proves
you did it that's authoritarianism the
adherence to the authority me i've
always been libertarian i dropped out of
high school i said screw college i'm
gonna make my own way and decide for
myself and i don't care what you think
and you can't tell me what to do
conversely or subsequently i don't want
to tell you what to do either just leave
me alone those are the big differences
but isn't populism and libertarianism in
tension with each other
um not necessarily why why why do you
think that because libertarianism to me
signifies like
free trade and well that's big l liberty
you're like a civil libertarian civil
libertarian yeah yeah it's just a do you
have a tendency towards live and let
live or do you have a tendency towards
do as you're told right what we should
call liberalism except liberals exactly
don't believe in that new york city now
st paul uh minneapolis they're now
enforcing a vaccine mandate cook county
the second biggest county in the country
vaccine mandate and we're watching
record covid cases
so what is the point of the vaccine
mandate
they repeatedly say it works that on tv
they say it works in new york they say
it works
well it's not stopping kovid
oh but the vaccine minutes are
getting people to drop down bend the
knee and give in to your authority
in that in that sense it is working and
that's exactly what they mean when they
say it works
yeah and they're finding people and then
i look at luke
i'm already i i already have something
lined up i'm sure you're talking about
what was happening in quebec with of
course the premier there setting up a
tax on the unvaccinated he's calling it
a health contribution but in reality
it's just theft uh the prime minister of
canada justin trudeau also says that he
supports this strong measure and most
likely will be implementing uh this kind
of exploitative measure on the canadian
public as a collective you better be a
part of our gang or we're going to steal
your money that's essentially what's
happening right now in quebec and what's
going to happen nationally throughout
canada in a few days look at this
article from the l.a times mocking
anti-vaxxer's deaths is ghoulish yes but
necessary it is yes no no it isn't it
convinces no one of anything
what is the purpose of mocking an
anti-vector's death
seriously it's to gloat so that people
on your side can laugh and feel like
they're part of the the group i call it
a cult because the way cults work is
convincing a person that everyone loves
you you're right you're on the right
side and they're the crazy people don't
listen to them don't talk to them is
that a photo of the author no that's a
photo of one who died yeah due to covet
who opposed mandates okay because i was
going to say that that's like of that
publication to use the photo of the
author would have been like clearly
signaling what had happened here which
was like they knew that this piece was
going to go viral for hate and they were
putting a target on the back of the
author and they like this is something
no edit i'm saying this is an opinion
editor this piece got a ton of track the
kind of traffic like you dream of as an
editor i would never have let somebody
write that because
you just know that it's it's so ghoulish
and it's just going it's only going to
get hate shares and essentially it's
like
this this editor just did not have the
back of that writer it's not just one
editor i mean how many people are
probably involved in the process of this
getting approved
so if our goal is to make a better
country and to help people
do you think it makes sense to go to
someone whose wife just died of covet
and laugh and mock them and say your
wife's up an effing [ __ ] what a dumb
piece of garbage haha and then high five
your friend is that going to convince
them to to join you is it going to
convince them to get vaccinated
no so actually interestingly people
don't know this but um
walmart has had a campaign to help
vaccinate people and it has been
incredibly successful in the two most
vaccine-hesitant populations
african-americans and trump voters as
well as evangelicals big overlap there
and when they asked them like why are
you succeeding with these populations
that nobody else can get vaccinated
their answer was we're meeting people
where they're at and they had they
they partnered with low local leaders
who had a lot of trust in the community
sports teams or pastors or there was one
community of latinos who were very
vaccine hesitant and they found a local
publication in spanish and they had a
press conference in spanish and then
partnered with an immigration center and
so you know i i know you guys are
probably ambivalent about this but
basically what they found was that
meeting people where they were at was
the vaccine like that was how you but it
was the opposite of a mandate and
opposite of shaming
respect respecting people's distrust
because you earned their distrust by
being you know you know untrustworthy
yeah do you do you uh is there there is
there is zero improvement in this
country by mocking people you you uh you
know who have opposed mandates
if someone's wife dies of covid and you
show up you're wearing a suit at the
funeral and you walk over and you pat
him on the shoulder and shake his hand
and say i'm sorry for your loss i'm here
if you need anything here's my number
seriously give me a call we'll grab a
drink at any time and then you can have
those conversations and then you can say
well you know look man i mean you look
at these numbers and people who are
vaccinated are less likely to be
hospitalized you have a real
conversation and the person might still
disagree but you're having a real
conversation are you familiar with daryl
davis yes
perfect example oh god he's amazing
he's the black jazz musician who said um
i just want to meet these these racists
who hate me who never met me that was it
he didn't have a plan to de-radicalize
klansmen he just said i'm gonna go talk
to him he drove the children of a
klansmen to see their father in jail
every week for years
and they were still racist i mean it
took years for them to stop he's amazing
yeah he just he was like well you know
how they gonna know if they don't know
and you gotta talk to them and that's
and that's exactly exactly it so it is
tough though because we we have we have
the data and we discuss it quite a bit
people on the left
traditionally do not follow people on
the right and don't seek to engage with
them people on the right are the inverse
they constantly seek to engage in people
on the left and they consume news from
uh all you know different political
spectrum political outlets in 2016 this
is what jack dorsey said
left journalists liberal journalists did
not follow right-wing journalists but
right-wing journalists follow both right
and left-wing journalists so this is why
a lot of people on the right weren't
surprised that trump won we had um i
think it was max kaiser who's not a
right-wing journalist or anything he's a
financial guy
he said uh it was him and stacy they're
you know very they have the orange pill
podcast you guys check it out if you're
interested in crypto they were in europe
i could be getting the story wrong but
the general i i remember as they were in
europe and they were hearing all across
the media that trump could never win
that everyone hated him and it was it
was a slam dunk for hillary and they
flew back to the u.s and landed in north
carolina and saw nothing but support for
trump signs everywhere and they
immediately said trump's going to win
but why was the media so disconnected
because they don't follow anyone but
themselves
so we see that still today we actually
pulled up there's a website called
ground.news
and you can put in someone's twitter
handle and see
the political bias of the outlets they
interact with when we pulled up
left-wing personalities it was like 80
to 100 left-wing
when you pull up moderate personalities
it's mixed when you pull up
conservatives
it leans conservative with a little bit
of left in there
but many uh conservative personalities
follow left with publications
people on the left don't do the same
thing but again i just want to make the
point that like
that sounds like a story about politics
but it is also very much a story about
class you know if these journalists
lived in working-class neighborhoods or
knew any working-class people they would
not have been so shocked by trump's
victory but they don't they live in
these extremely affluent wealthy you
know hillary clinton plus 20 districts
and this is data has showed this a a
political survey found that you know
journalists 75 of journalists live not
just in blue districts but in the most
blue districts
looks like a story about about politics
but is actually a story about class
about how you know the republican party
became the party of the working class
and the democrats became the party of
you know big tech wall street which gave
more money to biden into trump and then
highly educated liberal elites did you
see this story in 2016 from vox
june 3rd 2016
leftwingpublicationvox.com democrats are
replacing republicans as the preferred
party of the very wealthy and that is
true today and the neocon establishment
conservatives like the lincoln project
fled to support democrats and even after
2020 the lincoln project said now we're
going to go after republicans in the
senate and conservatives were like why
we thought you were the party of lincoln
you just opposed trump no
they're establishment politicians my
favorite story maybe you saw it
was during the george floyd riots
there was a guy in la
who was cheering on the riding saying
yeah yeah get it go go until the rider
started coming to beverly hills and then
he tweets something like no don't come
to my neighborhood why are you coming
here go downtown
it was amazing to see the contempt and
disdain for regular people as the riders
were destroying the neighborhoods of the
poor and he cheered them on and then
panicked we got to be careful that we
don't get too excited about the the
vindication as the the wealthy start to
suffer as their dollar gets closer and
closer to the value of zero because the
french revolution you just look at past
revolutions where people rise up against
the elite it can go really bad really
fast and you don't know who's going to
try and take power if something like
that were to happen
oh yeah rather than revel in in seeing
them fall maybe we can help them and and
help them change
their behavior it's not about the
wealthy
it's about the um
what who are the you know these these
the the nobles that would enter that
would inbreed and then you know god
nobles
it was pretty much all of them yeah and
there was the royal families yeah there
was one famous family where like the guy
was like
oh yeah it's like his jaw was all messed
up i'm like that's how i view most of
these people
they they they are the product of this
um insular culture they've developed
where they isolate themselves from
regular people they come from old money
they're extremely arrogant and
disdainful and they think they're better
than you
and and and i again uh i know people
i've met people throughout my life who
came from wealthy families who became
yes
became very humble and they were like
i'm really you know
i know some people who are wealthy who
are born into rich families who would
say you know i'm really careful to um
enter politics or anything like that
because i've not experienced what most
of the people have gone through and so i
don't want to assert myself over people
i'm like that's the right way to do it
man so tim was referring to a very
famous family called the hapsburgs since
like 1273 and they were notoriously in
an inbreeding family and developed this
weird lip
jaw deformity looking thing so check out
the hapsburg
most monarchies are in bread yeah and
they would do that because to maintain
keep wealth within the family yeah you
know you'd have to sell half your wealth
to your your son's wife if you're if his
wife is your daughter yeah
yeah
or cousin gross i don't know i'm fairly
optimistic when i see when i see look
the success that we have everybody who's
a member at timcast.com everybody who
supports us in super chats we're growing
we're hiring we're expanding we're doing
more every single day so as a news
organization how do we taking don't or
like you were saying with subscription
model we have a core group of people
that like what we do and
fortunately what you do journalist wise
is rip on everybody that's messing up
for the most part so maybe
you don't have to target a type of
person
you know how like the new york times is
going out of their way to to supplant
these
well look i i just um
i'm anti-authoritarian
that's that that's about it so if a
person is a working-class person but
they use their voice to try and force
other people to bend the knee i'm going
to criticize them for the most part
though i'm more concerned with the power
structures themselves and the ideas
which is why in a lot of stories we
don't say the person's name or will
specifically reference a person who did
this instead of calling out someone
individually i don't care about an
individual i care about the structure
and the system and the person but there
are some people who are so high profile
we talk about them it's it's it's you
know nobody's perfect right
it's it's not it's not a perfect uh
yeah there's no simple way to ignore
everybody but there are a lot of people
uh especially on youtube
and in the political space who their
whole career is insulting and targeting
a single person oh it gets so old so
fast yeah yeah
but you know look i'm optimistic i see i
see the populist growth the expansion
success and i think the censorship may
be bad but you know rumble's doing
really well there's more systems on the
rise i don't think you know
it's like all of these movies and
stories and heroes journeys uh all these
comic books about a villain who wants to
take over the world and they always fail
you cannot as an individual no single
human is smart enough to seize control
of everything and they fail every time
they try oh yeah and if they were to
succeed they'd be offed by the number
two in command in a holy second and then
that guy would be off by the number
three who would become the new you saw
in the roman empire that's why we don't
aim for
centralization of authority yep there
will come a a day where you know i walk
into the room and then everyone you know
takes a a rubber mallet hits me in the
back and then ian walks over and hits me
and i say i look up and i say you two
either time has come
you too ian let me get my hat
that's two
all right all right but uh until that
day we'll be like old
uh smash the like button
subscribe to this channel go to
timcast.com be a member we're gonna have
that member segment coming up at 11 pm
but we're gonna go to super chats right
now and take your guys questions and
comments it's gonna be a whole lot of
fun
all right let's see what we got here
uh for lorne vox says you lads better
stock up they're about to push vax
mandates for truck drivers this friday
yeah
so that's why um you know today i
shouted out safeandreadymeals.com
emergency food supplies it's one of our
sponsors i almost i don't chat about all
that often because it's like it's an
emergency food bucket but store shelves
are running empty
inflation is up seven percent
it really feels like everything is you
know getting worse and if they vax
mandate truckers you ain't get nothing i
i will say we went to the store the
other day and we saw empty shells and i
was like i don't know if this is normal
i don't know if it's a stock date but
i've never seen this before and the
other thing i would where was the store
that was right in frederick wow yeah
right my neighborhood i don't get it
truckers are alone in their trucks why
do they need a vaccine like
authoritarianism
it doesn't do anything other than say to
the person you do as you're told or else
do it yeah i was going to say though
that there have been places where
they've tried to put these vaccine
mandates in place and they have had to
walk them back they did it at my dad's
company because they were going to lose
a significant percentage of their highly
trained you know workers they're like oh
no we can't do this all right i guess we
have to walk it back so i'm very
optimistic that truck drivers are going
to be exerting the pressure to get them
to stop because this needs to end
here's a funny one nolan conway says hey
tim have carl benjamin on i think the
reason we're getting that comment is
because your last name is unger sargon
and carl benjamin goes by sargon of
akkad or he used to yeah i am the lesser
sargon
well
you know he's in the uk uh carl's a good
friend he's always welcome to come on
the show together
i would love to get carl and um i don't
know him is he what's his deal is he on
twitter
no he's banned from twitter yeah yeah
he's pretty um because he was relatively
controversial like three or four years
ago for getting banned for saying some
off-color well you could argue their
off-color comments on another platform
or on another another person's
show and then they came and they banned
his channel and it was really really
scandalous
john chambers has a good idea says you
need an event january 22nd as many of us
are coming to dc for the january 23rd
anti-mandate march well we
what what we do have a really big sorry
i wasn't sure if you were going to throw
it to her but i was going to say we do
have a really big show planned for that
monday because people are going to be in
town for that rally and that's kind of
exciting so you guys oh we do have a big
show 17th yes it's big it's really big i
know you know what i'm talking about
it is yeah it's gonna be great maybe
it's okay i know what you're talking
about it's it's hard it's all right well
we should definitely reach out to the
people at the event yeah that's a really
good idea i like that i think i'm going
to be attending that event myself
dr malone peter mccullough the
weinsteins there's a surprise celebrity
guest as well that they're kind of
telling like say it's going to be big so
i think robert kennedy jr as well i
don't know if he's a hundred percent
confirmed but it's gonna it's going to
be a lot of people i'm gonna be there
definitely i wouldn't want to take this
event it's a saturday absolutely so that
friday is the 22nd i wonder if um
any of you any any any of y'all who are
going to be at that event um i want to
come on the show let's get all three of
them let's get mccullough let's get
weinstein let's get malone all three
here that would be incredible and robert
kennedy jr let's set up extra cameras
that would be huge
asking for
trouble on youtube
absolutely that'd be fantastic super fun
but we'll talk about mandates we'll talk
about policy and then you know we'll
we'll do we can do a um
a members only maybe like a rumble
exclusive before or after the show
talking about other other issues be
funny
that'd be really great so if uh if y'all
are listening and you all are down um
i'll i'll i'll hit some of these people
up that'd be fantastic yeah it'd be fun
also weinstein if you ever need it like
einstein the smart guys or weinsteins
not weinstein like epstein that's what i
said that's one way to remember that's
fair or or uh was it like a weinstein he
was bigger we jews got to be clear what
kind of jews we are these days yeah
let's
be crystal clear that would be like an
epstein would be like a weinstein an
einstein yeah i like that i approve that
that's nice that's hard oh this is crazy
andrew kolasar says spin doctors have
ousted their star bassist mark white for
refusing to get the jab he's on
instagram mark b white also check out my
music i love the spin doctors man at
least in the name of name more than one
song uh little miss can't be wrong two
princes
uh
pocket full of kryptonite dude that
album is awesome
what's the one song everyone knows from
them 4 30. what time is it no no uh
little miss can't be wrong or two
princes those are the two huge heads two
princes yeah
[Laughter]
johnny california says vice was cool
back when when all they did was hang out
in colombia
doing donkeys for less
uh vice used to be fun
you know they would go on the ground and
explore weird things bulletproof
clothing the sex shop in japan
scopolamine and now they're all just
ultra woke tribalists
the big banks came in
no that that is what yeah so i was told
by someone who was a higher up at a vice
the investors were concerned about
negative press and cancel culture so
they told the executives either you go
woke and embrace feminism or we revolt
and so they did
and they're like all right that's what
we'll do and it was around you know 2014
or so brought to you by bank of america
wraith customs firearm says luke don't
tase me bro they tased yeah it was
pretty funny it wasn't like a long taser
it was like he surprised us with it too
because we were there
and we were
filming and then out of nowhere he's
like okay i'm going to teach you you
know this stuff and he's like
that came out of nowhere
and he didn't say like hey get prepared
we're gonna taser you do you have any
heart conditions he was just a wild
crazy guy who was super interesting and
super fun and i wish uh we would have
released that video because it was just
wild and then
like literally me and tim got got
sat together we didn't know what was
going on he he liked surprises this guy
tim was sitting back back to back to me
and then he throws something and
he and then he says we're going to see
who stays here longer i'm like all right
and then it was like five seconds yeah
and we were both like nope yeah yeah i
know some like serious tear gas which is
all right brett s says congrats to tim
poole's beanie for making it into itunes
number one hip-hop song controlled by
bryson gray featuring anomaly
and then he says something i can't read
because it's in polish
oh yeah that's rovia how do you say that
what does that mean uh
you don't want to know okay gotcha
it's like whoa
he's lying luke's alive looks like he's
making it up thank you for your
controversy i am not a good liar
it says keep it up guys that's what it
means thank you sir maybe i don't know
you know you don't know polo that's true
well ian can you google translate i'm
translating it right now yeah how do you
spell that i don't tell them don't help
them
i don't know spell it
hunter says hi tim cass slight
correction to something said the other
day with brandon you did not need a
license in texas to buy a handgun in
texas before constitutional carry just
to carry one in public
uh
oh really i i read somewhere that you
need to take a handgun course
you have to get like a special training
or something
you know along those lines i learned uh
not i've been talking a lot about
student loans and compound interest and
how students are getting rocked by it
most student loans i found this out
someone messaged me on twitter thank you
for sending this are not compoundly
interested they're just standard
interests i didn't know that but that's
most student loans are standard interest
and not compound grant thompson he's got
some words for you he says this woman
didn't watch the trial only the
prosecution stated that he died of
strangulation despite him having a
lethal drug dose an enlarged heart
covered 19 and o2 saturated blood
eg he could breathe
well my understanding from having
watched the trial was that the based on
his not to speak speaking of the dead
but his habitual drug use that that that
the amount that he had ingested
beforehand would not have been enough to
cause cardiac arrest and that the
cardiac arrest was caused by the
strangulation and that that some part of
that was not disputed by the prosecution
but thank you for the corrections did
didn't he have a lethal dose of fentanyl
i thought he did three times lethal for
sure had an intoxicative dose yeah but
they they face the the the uh
prosecution stipulated that based on the
level of his habitual use
which they got from one of the witnesses
who was his girlfriend and his son he
was a very big man yeah um and his you
know his level of muscularity and his
workout etc that that would not have
been lethal i'll tell you my thoughts
right away
you shouldn't go to prison for doing
drugs
you shouldn't
uh none of this should have happened
over a counterfeit bill yeah but he was
behind the wheel of a car while chewing
a speedball yeah and this is what got
him pulled out and detained and then if
you watch the body camera footage he's
resisting arrest
the first time
the first
the
oh you mean when he was arrested yeah
yeah so he's sitting in the suv chewing
on a speed ball behind the wheel of a
car yeah and you know i've i've often
like i've argued the libertarian point
of like people should be allowed to do
drugs everyone comes back with duties
behind the wheel of a car an suv no less
and i'm like that's a good point man
like i'm all for allowing people to do
whatever recreational drugs they want
but you can't drive if you're doing it
and so the cops pulled him out to detain
him when they brought him to the police
suv he kicked his way out of the car
screaming put me on the ground put me on
the ground put me on the ground three
times and they did
whether or not that warrants four people
going to prison for the rest of their
lives i honestly don't think so i do
think there's fault i mean when you
watch the video
all of that could be true he could have
even put his knee on his neck for until
he was subdued i think the problem was
he was subdued and he kept his knee on
his neck for five minutes after he was
no longer moving that's true and it's
like what is going through your head at
that point when this person is saying i
can't breathe i can't breathe i can't
breathe and then totally passed out
under your knee like at what point do
you have criminal liability for
someone's life
but is it life in prison or is it like
manslaughter in a few years you know
i mean like how was justice served by
four people the three rookie cops who
were just who showed up confused having
no idea what was going on now while
going to prison for the rest of their
lives
okay so i don't i as a person who
doesn't bel you know i'm sort of very
ambivalent about the cultural state i
hear that point at the same time like i
think we have to say that human life is
infinitely precious and when you
participate in something that steals one
as a society we have to have a way to
say like
you were there to serve and protect and
you stole a life
and and it was like the look on their
face okay i'm like a lefty so of course
like you come back to the compassion and
the feeling or whatever but the looks on
their their imperviousness to his
suffering
to to the point where they allowed him
to literally die like they stole his
life when at any moment during those
nine minutes someone could have
intervened and they didn't let anybody
intervene
it's it's it's it's this is the problem
i have with authoritarianism and
collectivism those three cops not
chauvin were doing as they were told
i don't know if they deserve to go to
life in prison because they were just
doofy and just sitting there confused
and not have they been sentenced to life
in prison well they're they're they're
getting they're all getting i think
federal civil rights charges
so okay maybe maybe um it's a little
hyperbole i think they're gonna get life
in prison but i think they're gonna get
decades
i mean like chauvin's never getting out
i don't know is a civil rights abuse i
don't know what the sentence for that is
but it's not murder
they're they're all charged with murder
aren't they am i wrong about that i'm
pretty sure they're all going to get a
murder charge and then a federal charge
on top and then they're probably going
to get a state prison sentence and then
transfer to a federal prison afterwards
like
i think the whole prison system is
busted up and so you know my problem
with all of this is that black lives
matter groups say you know abolish
prisons abolish police and then the
moment they get a poor victory they
cheer and say lock them up i know i
don't want to be one of those i'm like
you know i think about human life and
the preciousness i
i get that's a that's a risky path to go
down because like
stealing someone's life and doing
something that might create a situation
where it's harder for them to survive
are very different like if if my if
living my most just life means that
there's no food for those people i
didn't steal life from them they're just
gonna starve because i was the one that
beat the system no but in that case your
life is infinitely precious as well
anything you do to keep yourself alive i
think is consistent with that principle
there's a lot of this i mean in the
torah you have to save yourself before
you save others that's
i think one of the problems i see with
the whole chauvin thing and i want to go
too long on this because it's like an
old issue with a lot of questions but
when the the prosecutor's defense the
prosecution's defense said
according to protocol chauvin was
entitled to use more force than he did
use that showed restraint
but all of his bosses who had trained
him disputed that so the this was the
thing that was so amazing to me about
this trial and i really i agree you know
i'm sure actually i know i'm sure your
viewers are dying to hear what you what
you think about it but to me it seemed
like it was a trial about the nature of
policing and it was the prosecution that
had an optimistic view of policing in
america and said this is not what it
means to be a cop to be a cop is an
honorable position and they brought on
cops who broke the blue wall for the
first time to say this is not what we
were trained to do and it was the
defense who had this pessimistic ugly
view of what it means to be a police
officer who are like no this was just
like policing you know as it's supposed
to be so do you think that
what we got was making an example of
someone no
the the i mean those three those three
other cops didn't have their knee on the
neck should they be charged for this not
for murder no but they're all being
charged yeah so that would be i think an
overstatement but um chauvin showed up
late
he showed up after everything had
already happened and they said we need
help doing this guy and then he walked
over and he he put him in the in the
restraint where
uh it's it's so complicated to rehash so
maybe we shouldn't but yeah it wasn't
just that his knee was on his neck for
nine minutes that was debunked in the
trial his knee was on the back and the
neck back and forth or for a certain
amount of time that doesn't change the
fact that he could have stopped at any
moment and provided medical treatment or
anything so that argument i understand
but i think we just what we have right
now in our judicial system is
retribution to to placate rioters and
that's what we've been getting across
the board that's why the car right now's
trial was so monumentous for a lot of
people okay so i see a little bit
differently and this okay leaving floyd
aside to me that week where we had the
written house trial come in verdict come
in and then the ahmad arbory trial come
in which was wrong what they did no the
the the the conviction the sentencing
really the guy who filmed it who had
nothing to do with the two mcmichaels
what about the mcmichaels
so that's that's that's a whole
philosophical debate i mean if the
police come to your house and say we
need you to help stop this guy he's a
burglar some burglary suspect he's a
felon and then you see the guy running
down the street after your neighbor says
he broke into his house or he was seen
trespassing in the house which makes him
a felony burglary suspect
some people are gonna say okay this is
the guy the cops were looking for we're
gonna go stop him
what do you think uh
i think you shouldn't get in your truck
and go chase a guy down you should call
the cops but it's it's not an issue
about what i think it's an issue of do
these guys deserve life in prison after
the these are some you know look i'm not
trying to be mean but dumb local guys in
their community that has been plagued by
burglaries they the burglaries were so
intense that a gun had been stolen from
one of i believe one of their trucks
only three weeks prior so there was a
fear that whoever the suspect was was
armed the neighbor had just seen this
guy enter his property in the middle of
the night illegally
it's it's burglary when you enter a
property in this jurisdiction and then
the police go door to door and say this
is the guy we're looking for and then
one day these guys are like that's him
the guy the cops are looking for has
been terrorizing the neighborhood
so the younger mcmichael grabs a shotgun
they flank the guy
ahmed aubry is running towards them he
could have run through the grass he
could have done a lot of things granted
if someone pulls a gun on me i might be
like i'm going to subdue them too
arbory goes around the truck and then
grabs the shotgun from travis mcmichael
and fights for it the gun goes off in
the struggle killing ahmed arboree
now you'd have an argument about whether
they were justified in in trying to do a
citizen's arrest based on the law and
that's where the real question came up
in the conviction
but look at what happened to the guy who
followed behind
a guy saw what was going on saw them
running after chasing after the car and
he said i'm gonna film this and because
he filmed it the criminal trial happened
in the first place so they're putting
this guy in prison for the rest of his
life the whole thing is busted and
broken and it was just to placate riders
okay so i stayed a little bit
differently and it's funny because i
so the thing that i thought was so
interesting was
i i think he was lynched i think they
chased him down and killed him because
he they wouldn't have they would have
made the mistake about who it was if he
wasn't black and then what mistake did
they make
that was the guy the police said they
were looking for
he's on security camera footage
illegally he had not stolen anything but
that's not what makes you a felony
burglary suspect right so stuff had gone
missing a gun had gotten stolen power
tools had been stolen but that night
prior so the police said we're looking
for this guy but he had not actually
stolen anything from the property that
he had entered which was like this
construction site but that doesn't
that's not relevant to the case the
prosecution even said he was a felony
burglary suspect
so
this is a mistake i made and we actually
had a couple lawyers on i said look a
guy who trespasses shouldn't be chased
down and then you know confront him and
i think it was andrew branca who said no
he was a felony burglary suspect
irrespective to whether or not someone
saw him on camera in a building this
there was a string of burglaries at the
neighborhood he was the suspect that's
what the police told the mcmichaels
so they said that's the guy the cops are
looking for and they explained that
their intention was to stop him if you
watch the video they pull in front of
him yeah they don't chase him down yeah
and
aubry run towards them runs towards them
and goes around the right side of the
truck and then flanks left and grabs the
shotgun well because they were aiming at
it i mean they were trying to stop it
well we can't see that
we we can't see if travis mcmichael
actually aimed the shotgun at ahmed arby
what we can see is he turns right around
the truck and then turns left and
grabbed and then the next thing you see
is they're fighting over right now
people are trying to you know arrest you
and they have a gun it's a reasonable
thing to
but i to me that the thing the point i
wanted to make is that the written house
trial was so disgustingly politicized
and got so much attention by liberals
who were trying to cast um not just kyle
rittenhouse but anyone who's defended
him as white supremacists right they
were even they tried so hard to give the
impression that he had killed black
people right this actually got
misreported in one outlet
yes
it was in a book it's in a book that he
killed three black people even in the
like more legitimate outlets what they
did was they would say you know he he
shot three people and killed two at a
black lives matter rally right to try to
give the impression even if they weren't
outright saying it and it was so
disgustingly politicized in that way and
i met so many liberals who truly
believed that he had shot black people
and when i would say no he shot a
pedophile
a domestic abuser and a guy who punched
his grandmother earlier that week they
would be like oh i'm not following it
closely i'm not following closely and
i'm like oh you're following it closely
enough to get it wrong right but then
when the ahmed arbory verdict came in i
was watching fox news all day and they
were cheering that verdict and and every
conservative i know was saying like
those men got what they deserved they
chased that boy down and and because
they're cowards but the well okay no no
i want to i really want sorry to
interrupt but i want to stress this
conservatives these people all of them
who spoke out and cheered on that
verdict are cowards who are too scared
to speak out when the george floyd thing
happened on principle many people on the
right were like that's clearly wrong we
can see his knee on his neck and then
when the body camera footage came out
and more more in context came out a lot
of people on the right were like well i
was wrong about that for me to see
everything we covered in the ahmed
arbory case which is not as it's not
clear-cut
the media was reporting it just like
written out that it was a lynching that
white guy white guys chased down a
jogger this guy was not a jogger that is
a lie and people on the right gleefully
were like see this proves the system
works because they're cowards and
they're scared they're still scared they
will still peddle the line for the left
but they want to do it at the speed
limit that's the difference that's the
difference between the right and the
left for the most part
i i took a look at uh i covered the
almond arbory story we had a guy in the
studio screaming at me calling me racist
because i dared say any of this stuff
but i don't care what he thinks i don't
care what tulsi gabbard thinks because
she called it the right verdict i don't
care what fox news says they are all
wrong when it came down to the
conviction on ombud arbory what happened
was the prosecutor said
there there's a citizen's arrest law
that says you are allowed to or to
perform perform a citizen's arrest if
you have probable cause and you
witnessed a crime take place however if
it's a felony you need only probable
cause a reasonable person concludes if
there is a felony suspect you need not
have witnessed the crime but the
prosecutor argued no it's one it's one
provision therefore
regardless of whether whether or not
it's a felony you had to have witnessed
it on that instruction from the judge
the jury said well in that case they're
guilty
however if you actually read the law it
says if someone is trying to citizens
arrest a felony suspect they don't need
to have witnessed the crime in which
case the mcmichaels are stupid but they
were genuinely chasing down a felony
suspect as they were informed but did
they know that law or does it not matter
i don't think they knew much about the
law at all other than the police said
we're looking for this guy and they said
we're going to stop him and they were
concerned he was the guy who had stolen
the gun from their truck so if someone
steals a gun from your truck the gun is
missing you've reported it missing and
then you're told by the cops we think
that's the guy who did it are you going
to show up unarmed no definitely not so
what ends up happening is
all i all like you know willing to say
well wish me more otherwise we'll just
keep keep going
the fact that the guy who filmed it
which allowed the court case to happen
got life in prison and they're cheering
for it just says to me
you need only see that point and then
you need to then question the rest of
the case this guy got in his car and
said i'm going to film this and that's
all he did and they said we're going to
charge you with murder now and he was
like but i didn't do anything we don't
care we want you to rot and suffer
because we're scared of riots that's the
same thing with mick michaels they're
doofy dopey yokel guys who were told by
the cops this is the burger burglary
suspect they were stupid for doing it
but i don't think they lynched anybody i
don't think they were intentionally
trying to cause harm and sending them
the prison for the rest of their lives
does not serve justice
but people don't
they don't care they want to feel good
they want to feel like the system works
fox news doesn't want to be perceived as
racist so when they cheer for kyle
rittenhouse they get scared that too
many people are going to be like why are
you cheering for this guy they got their
victory so they come out and they can
they can say see ahmed arbory that case
was ruled correctly and then we sit down
with lawyers and they're like look at
the facts and i'm like wow that was
wrong
so anyway
we'll keep going so i'll read some more
super chats and you know because
otherwise we're gonna go too long
tara says tim calories in calories out
has been debunked please watch watch fat
fiction on youtube it's very eye opening
into how calories from sugar is
dangerous i believe you are correct yes
i'm not a nutritionist but when i say
you can't gain weight if you don't eat
the calories
i'm still pretty sure that's a fact yeah
you can't gain weight by just breathing
air
um so if you are not consuming calories
you can't gain weight
but i think you know i hear people like
neil degrasse tyson say calories in
calories out and i'm like that's not
true man i cut out sugar just sugar and
i would like eat tons of salami and i'm
losing yeah a calorie is a heat a
measurement of heat that's produced when
your body digests a piece of food so you
get a lot of nutrition with specific
foods that are then the foods broken
down there might be the same amount of
heat produced with like a piece of sugar
but all that nutrition is there with the
broccoli also the sugar industry
absolutely very huge very corrupt and
has caused a lot of horrible things in
our society by buying off regulators and
government bureaucrats
brian doyce says great guest really
poignant conversation tonight thanks tim
cast peeps i agree i think this has
actually been a fantastic conversation
about about everything it's wonderful uh
christina h says i'd love to see anomaly
and or bryson gray on your show happy
wednesday love y'all i'd like to see
them both on the show yeah that'd be fun
yeah that would be fun we could actually
what if we had them on a friday and they
performed the song where they mentioned
my beanie yeah that was kind of my
thought it's it's flattery flattery will
get you everything literally everything
yeah do you have a copy of your book by
any chance did you bring one
okay
i would love to have you and chloe
valderate have you you know chloe
valderrer i'm actually on the board of
her theory of enchantment oh yeah
she's great you guys have a very cool
vibe
yeah we're very close we're great good
friends awesome
rocky says ian i love you man but i
cannot listen to you talk about sugar
being a toxin but actively pursue
psychedelics no one has died from a bad
cake trip that's that's that's wrong
that's not true that's true that's not
true heart disease and commodities
choking you gotta be careful um okay all
things in moderation i'm not saying
don't ever touch sucrose but treat it
like a like a powerful drug because it
can it makes you hunger for it it's a
different kind of addiction not where
you think like i want that it's just
like you're drawn towards it so you got
to watch out for that stuff and same
thing with psychedelics or any kind of
drug if you're ever going to experiment
with any of that uh be reasonable
you know and and and research it i'm not
advocating for that kind of thing but
you gotta small doses man with food or
with drug or with any kind of thing
silently in atlanta says omg luke you
forgot the other part of the kelly
osbourne latino gaffe story rosie perez
quit after being forced by show execs to
apologize for reacting to the racist
gaff abc forced latina to apologize for
being visibly offended by the guest
it was in 2015 but i think it's it's
relevant i just kind of vaguely
remembered it and that's why i looked it
up and but uh yeah it gets deeper and
crazier hillary wallace says calories in
calories out absolutely works it's the
law of thermodynamics follow the science
um that's a th that's that's not
completely follow fouch that's not
completely right
yeah he's the science i will say it's
really hard to accurately measure
calories out it's easier to measure
calories in but even that's wrong yeah
casey neistat did a great video where he
bought food around new york and then got
it calorie tested and found that like
subway actually had less calories than
they advertised and most foods had more
or like many of them did which is really
fascinating what i will say is
i in my personal opinion based on how
i've eaten i think everybody's different
when i eat grains and sugars i'm
miserable yeah i i have no energy i feel
just bad when i cut that stuff out and i
stick to fats meats cheeses and veggies
i feel like a million bucks so over the
past several months i've one thing i've
really noticed is
in the mornings
seven months ago i'd wake up i'd have my
coffee i'd put sugary creamer in it with
i put a little bit of creamer and then
some you know like flavored creamers i'm
like not too much sugar i'm trying to be
careful but still you know some sugar in
it and then i would drink that and then
as soon as i finish my morning segment
i'd have breakfast i'd have like a piece
of bread and some eggs and i'm like i'm
having a good breakfast here just like a
little piece of toast and some eggs and
bacon and then within few within 40
minutes to an hour i'd start getting
tired and drained and i'd be like oh man
i need to get something to drink or do
something and then i would get another
you know like another coffee or
something
when i stopped having all the sugars
now for breakfast i don't eat anything i
just have coffee with heavy cream and
nothing else you're doing intermittent
fasting too well i think the heavy cream
negates that yeah but i never get tired
there's there's no point where i get
sluggish or anything like that i'm
sustained throughout the day so i do all
of my morning segments without eating
anything and then as soon as i finish
i'll have a meal so today what did we do
we did uh keto hot dogs we did
portillo's famous hot dogs and we made
buns with almond flour and egg yeah
amazing nice grilled onions
and uh i feel great i don't get tired i
don't get sluggish and then over the
past few months there have been cheat
days where like it's the weekend we're
all going out to eat everyone's getting
dessert and i'm like
one time i can have you know a small
piece of this cheesecake it's no big
deal and the next day i'm just like
wait can you drink on keto can you have
beer can you have like liquors
very low in carbs i think you can have
liquors but you can't have beer yeah no
beer i don't drink anyway though
yeah yeah i don't know has that always
been true not when i was like 18 to 22 i
drank too much
but i don't really drink i just don't
get anything from it over the holidays i
had maybe like
maybe the month between november and
december
10 drinks
you know wow because i'm like people are
drinking they're having wine and we had
trump champagne it was hilarious and so
i partake maybe 10 is a little actually
uh a little much no no i think it's
right i had a couple beers too
yeah all right we'll treat a couple more
because i don't want to go uh too long
and we kind of did go too long so i
apologize for
that all right
what do we got here we got we got a
whole bunch of super chats
all right jdmc says rodney king happened
just before bush senior lost election
for second term
democrat old bag of tricks i don't know
about that that's a conspiracy theory
i've never heard yeah i mean either
clinton
staged or the democrats wanted the la
rights to happen or something clinton's
no old school i don't know that would no
the riots would actually help the
republican
you know no idea so what's the backfire
i don't know yeah
a lot of people are saying uh
can't wait to see anomaly on the show
yeah that'll be cool
working on that
all right let's see
a lot of people are commenting on the
george floyd thing which i i know if we
bring up we'll just rehash again and i
don't you know it's you know want to
sorry do it for the bonus section yeah
we can well i mean it's just me
jdmc says ian has been more awesome
since he came back from vacation love
you bro it's almost like something
happened to ian yeah like i fell asleep
on the plane when i woke up
[Laughter]
something new he woke up in a
parallel universe
yeah went through a time space i
actually did micro dose
psilocybin over the break and it was
incredible i i spent about 10 days in
ohio with my family and then i went out
to washington state out to the mountains
and was able to just have a just a
meditative
amazing amazing communication experience
with a great friend of mine out there
and
um i highly i highly recommend getting
some time away from a computer screen if
you can i think i tweeted a photo of you
in in nature i don't know if this is
this is exactly
i don't think that's me
beautiful picture i tweeted it thanks i
love it all right we'll do one more reel
real quick mr trench trucker says as a
trucker desperately trying to deliver
food i will not comply try to stop my
truck i dare you oh boy well
be responsible with your truck yes be a
good law-abiding truck driver but stand
up for what you believe in and i think
you know
non-violence of disobedience is the way
we we can push for change while not
hurting other people right
all right let's see here's one more mava
says tim you're right about unhealthy
image of body weight i got down to a
healthy weight with keto and my
coworkers thought i was underweight when
i wasn't yep oh yeah my friends if you
haven't already smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share it with
your friends take that url post it
wherever you can or if you're listening
on the podcast we're on all podcast
platforms listen to us there tell your
friends about it go to timcast.com click
sign up we're gonna have a members only
segment coming up around 11 p.m is when
we post it so you don't want to you'll
you will not want to miss that
you can follow us everywhere tim cast
irl follow us on instagram for all of
our clips you can follow me on instagram
at timcast uh badia do you want to shout
anything out you have social media oh
boy um i am at bungersargon on twitter
and you can find i work at newsweek i
try to platform working class voices and
voices from across the political
spectrum so you can find those op-eds at
newsweek.com and you can find my book at
amazoncounter.com bad news how woke
media is undermining democracy thanks so
much tim and i'll just say one real
quick thing too
newsweek for like a mainstream corporate
press wonderful you'd publish a lot of
dissenting opinions you've got populist
right-wing people conservatives left i
think it's fantastic i saw a new article
where they said that covid lives in fat
cells it was a story out of china they
had to recall all this uh ice cream
because they've had tested
and it's like news we printed it and
then just like where where did that
information go if it's living in animal
fat no
but thank you so much for coming on it
was great being able to have a civil
discussion i know we don't see things
eye to eye but i think we could identify
the problems i think we definitely agree
on that and it was great being able to
understand your perspective where you're
coming from and being able to have a
silver discussion so thank you so much
for having that i have my own kind of
discussions and debates and
conversations on we are change.org i
just had a very important video on the
way that i think things are run in
context to of course epstein a usa today
article i did a video about that
exclusively on
lukeuncensored.com hope to see some of
you guys there thanks so much for having
me and uh thank you guys for uh
participating in the chat as well oh
yeah it was great uh you can follow me
in crossland.net gotcha good to see you
have a nice night guys see you later i'm
gonna take a moment because this is very
important to me i don't usually ask for
much time but i had a gift sent to me
that is the most one of the most
beautiful things i think i've ever seen
she made this portrait of my cat some of
you guys are familiar with dip and dot
um and it is amazing it's opalescent it
is made with glass and it has little
whiskers on it that move when you touch
them the little hairs uh her name is
lori kfar and she's at lkf designs on
instagram if you guys like to follow her
she does customized pet portraits just
like dip
absolutely amazing i'm so touched such a
generous gift she also did one of bucko
she had one of luke's dog and some of
the chickens as well so i am just amazed
by the gravity of this gift she also
made me these earrings and i'm going to
definitely work with her in the future
you guys may follow me
on twitter at sour patch lids thank you
lori they got a mosaic of atlas it looks
incredible there's a mosaic for you too
yeah roberto
and you could see the mosaic and the
unraveling on the vlog
just released today that was it so cool
all right everybody we will see you at
timcast.com
thanks for hanging out bye guys
you